good try it now can can you
muted I'm not sure how to do it well
can't we can just oh no your turn your
volume down I did
that
so next to the mute button there's a
Chevron if you open that up it should
[Music]
backing
represent
Peter
yes we hav't started
just welcome aboard for the
[Music]
Ino
ready did you want me to have it come
down and help
device
on
just getting worse I turned it
completely off it's off
complely shouldn't be me it shouldn't be
be a little late
but all right we can hear you just fine
now
sounds like we've got it solved
then if you decide you need to use it
again Mar I'll take a look at how to
turn the speaker off for you yeah we
[Music]
good this here and we can do it all
right all right you are all set to go
begun
morning as a chair of the house criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the co 19 pandemic in accordance with
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
with the potential for executive
sessions to be held throughout please
note that there is no fisical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
platform and the public has access to
contempor contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in a meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA
91a anyone who has a problem assessing
27136 or email
HCS
l.st do.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on meeting today on the
us it's actually not Brad geland it's uh
D please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room with you during the meeting
know chairman Welch I'm here A bunch
Republicans and a Democrats
representative ber I am here in
committee representative Spain I am here
in the committee room representative
green here representative Wallace
present representative testerman here
representative true pres in the
committee room representative PR here
representative Marston here the clerk is
present representative Harry gri
president in the committee room
representative
big present and I am in my home office
in Dober New Hampshire on I am
alone representative o'n president alone
representative
W uh here alone representative
new here and alone in my home office
representative Newman
here and alone representative Bon I'm
here and I'm at home representative
connley representative Klein Knight I'm
here and I'm at home and my sister's in
another room representative Bradley here
my daughters are with me chairman chair
is present in the room Mr chairman we
are just waiting for representative
CL I understand he'll be arriving around
9:30 today so we'll make sure we note
the record when he arrives yes at this
time we we will now open the public
hearing on house Hill
539 relative Mr
chairman oh thank representative Mar
repres Marson will you please lead us in
Allegiance I pledge
Al of the United States of America and
all time to public hearing for House
Bill 539 relative to records of
carers
yes he is Mr chairman would you like me
to
allowes josell you recognized to
introduce House Bill
539 thank you Mr chairman and uh members
of the
committee for the record my name is
representative Josh o Keller
representing Brentwood Danville and
Fremont I come to you uh today to
introduce and ask for your support of my
bill HB
539 uh RSA 7 col
6-b allows the AG to demand customer
data of communication common carriers
without a search warrant and I want to
bring uh this law in line with our new
Constitutional Amendment article 2B and
ensure that the a warrant for customer
data is required you have heard bills
like HB 597 which seeks to Bar
information like this um with uh from
the government agencies without search
warrants and I want to uh close this
loophole if such other bills were passed
also this uh law was passed in 2001 and
since then we have learned that the
government has used many Avenues to get
citizens personal data article 2B was uh
proposed and pass with overwhelming
support to help address the government
overreach and this law specifically
states that customer information from
your telephone and interet companies
must be handed over to the government
upon request and without a search
warrant I ask the AG's office for um how
many of these requests have gone out
since we amended our Constitution and
they uh turned that into a um 91a
request so they will get back to me in
uh by April 9th um so can't tell you at
the scope of the issue currently but um
its effects are
still um being had even if it's not
being actively used um my example of
this is the law is cited in state V Melo
which the Supreme Court uh let evidence
stand which was obtained based on a
warrant for which the warrant was later
thrown out and the court effectively
said that the information could be
attained without a warrant so no warrant
was required essentially opening this
information up to any agency as it
wasn't the AG that got the uh warrant in
thisa in the case that they were uh
talking about so as the legislature
flushes out what the
information um and uh personal
information is protected under article
2B I ask that you protect um you know
the customers's names and addresses and
billing records and more uh and close
this
loophole to our um government to gather
uh private information without a warrant
and I thank you and am happy to answer
any
questions representative thank you for
your testimony representative B you
recognize for a question thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question uh today it requires uh the
written demand of the Attorney General
to uh uh request this information
um which seems like be more difficult to
get than a uh search warrant uh search
warrants are uh routinely given by
case
so the the question of whether it's
easier or not I would go towards what is
the standard for such a request so in
search warrant
I would say that the standard is
probable cause whereas a demand it just
the attorney general just needs
reasonable
grounds um so I think that's a lower
standard to to reach and so that is um
my focus
of not necessarily whether it can be
handled by a phone call or whether it
needs to be a written demand but the
standard that is used and the the hurdle
that the um or the standard which the
government might use to be able to get
that customer information so thank you
for the question thank
you thank you representative
representative the chair could inquire
question and I want to thank you in
advance for taking my question uh are
you can you answer this whether does a
common carrier of the the communications
common carrier do they have absent
search for can they refuse the request
General so no th this is a shall um they
have to give so in in
um it says shall furnish to the attorney
general so there is no refusal if the
asks thank
you representative B you were recognized
for a question thank you Mr chairman and
uh thank you representative for your
testimony if I'm understanding correctly
this bill is only for you know my home
phone or cellier service not social
media or Google searches is that
correct thank you for the question so
common carrier is um defined in the
referenced RSA and um I don't believe
that it would uh so let's let me just
read the definition a person engaging in
or providing communication services to
the general public through transmission
of any form of information between
subscribers by means of wire cable radio
or
electromagnetic uh transmission Optical
or Fiber transmission or other means
which transfers information without
physical transfer of a medium whether to
be switched or or dedicated facility
and then it it carves out um radio and
television broadcast or any other
General Distribution of form of
communication s not be deemed
communication carrier So based on my
reading of that technically you are
giving the um you are
transferring um information between
people um probably via Optical or Fiber
Optic transmission since that's what
we're using to send stuff through the
internet so I think that it might
be it might be encompassing uh social
media all right thank
you representative expain you recognize
for a
question thank you Mr chair and I thank
the member for taking my question um can
you tell me what the in my understanding
of this this is currently only the AG
that can then make this request which
would mean that the AG
uh is typically only handling criminal
things can you tell me if there's bleed
through with a warrant that would open
this to civil actions and then also open
up such Avenues as um civil actions
within family courts divorce proceedings
and the
like thank you for the question so in
the RSA Tech um the AG can designate
both the county attorneys and um in
certain rsas to enforce certain rsas and
um the assistant AG to be able to make
such demands also uh the bleed through
that I'm seeing to to other agencies is
the Supreme Court ruling that if you can
get this information without a search
warrant that the um the law enforcement
agency which is not the AG was able to
uh essentially have this information
without a warrant introduced into a case
and so that's kind of bleeding the line
of it just is the AG to pretty much
anyone else um that is a law enforcement
agency I don't think I I have any
evidence that it's bled all the way into
um civil cases though follow
up you recog ask for a followup question
thank you Mr chair so under current law
um
in a a civil action such as a small
claims
action say a builder who taking action
against somebody who refused to pay or
what have you any of that would not be
accessible a builder could not uh as
part of his small claims action demand
that the cell phone records and Media
Records of the person that they're suing
be turned over to them
um by
lowering this to a warrant standard then
if the small claims court the lower
court decided a warrant was appropriate
they gave a warrant they could actually
demand all the electronic records from
somebody in something as simple as a
small claims case or even in a divorce
case or the like is that not
true thank you for the question I don't
believe this opens up any additional
Avenues because currently if a if a
judge wants to
uh Grant a search warrant for these
companies that that would still be um
honored so it's currently allowed it's
just um to to uh for people to be
subject to search warrants so I think
it's only um
re uh making sure that something below
reasonable uh
suspicion or uh the requirements of a
search warrant are met so right now it's
the AG just needs to have a suspicion of
something that might have been
criminal happening and so for the demand
whereas Reasonable Doubt has a higher
standard so thank you for the
question representative Muse you
recognized yes thank you for taking my
question um I'm wondering how your bill
addresses uh location data
and uh and potentially uh things like
real-time pinging uh by police officers
which are uh requests that uh that will
carriers thank you for the question we
actually have another law that deals
with um information data but uh this
this
doesn't this bill does not address that
as it is not
um uh it is so the the bill actually or
the RSA lists a specific number of
things that the people can request and
location data isn't one of them so I
don't believe that it's within the scope
of this RSA I think it's it's in a
different RSA but thank you for the
you representative Newman you
recogniz thank you Mr chair and thank
you to the witness taking my my question
would this have any effect on um what I
I when I read an article trying to
figure out what this bill meant it
talked about geofencing where they get
mega dat within a specific geographic
area like they're doing on the
Insurrection at the capital would this
have any effect on the Gathering of that
kind of information that originally is
only the location and then based on that
they get I I'm not sure whether they
have to get a search warrant or not to
get the additional information like that
would this affect that particular
activity so since since this was uh is
very similar to the last question and
what is covered so in the RSA it says
um that they shall furnish um names
addresses of persons who are stated
listed or unlisted telephone numbers uh
phones and
addresses of um anyone with a identified
server Serv anyone uh any local or
longdistance billing
records uh telephone customers Service
uh Records um the length of the service
provided um the types of Services
telephone numbers so it I think this is
really um focused on trying to get uh
people's telephone numbers and and other
subscriber like billing records I don't
think that it would it's not
specifically mentioned like Geo fencing
or location data and that is
specifically addressed in our say 644a I
believe uh the regulations around
location data and so I think that would
be is the I think it's probably outside
of the scope of this as as it doesn't
specifically carve out um exception to
644a thank you for the question thank
you representative
GA thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question if this became law
this bill what impact would this have
would have had on um getting the records
of those of the Insurrection that
capital thank you for the question I I
believe this was very similar to the
last question um nothing I don't believe
no this is the uh so I just described
the the types of things and first and uh
that would be covered under this and
location data is is governed by a
different RSA thank you for the
question thank
you your hand is raised you have another
question
question seeing no further hands raised
I want to thank the representative for
oh excuse me representative true thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question could
you could you give me some uh examples
information on my
phones somebody would want that they
don't have access to already just I
concrete examples of what information
for thank you for the question um so in
the case of the state V Melo they were
asking
for essentially they had an i IP
address and they were asking for you
know the name address phone number etc
etc of that person uh based on the IP
address so like the same thing would be
like if they had your telephone number
if you called
someone and um the the the AG or whoever
law enforcement agency was trying to
track down who who this phone number
belongs
to they would try and go to a specific
agency and say okay give me all of the
records that you have for this phone
number kind of a thing and so they would
be getting that data that way does that
you seeing no further hands raised I
want to again thank the representative
excuse
for any members of the public who who
wish to testify that are in attendance
please raise your hand at this time uh
for the purposes of this hearing
testimony will be limited to two minutes
for witness the chair now recognizes
Penny
Dean whoops thank you very much chairman
um my name is Penny Dean I'm an attorney
and I believe that there's rampant abuse
of this this is a
basically a fishing Expedition license
for the attorney general and to a and
his designes and to answer the question
about what information imagine any of us
has a
smartphone
and handing it to someone else and allow
them to fish through it to see the
telephone numbers you called the amount
of time you talk to them the frequency
at which you talk to them the numbers
you called your text messages your
emails what you search and at least my
concern always is in general but for gun
owners if you want to see who gun owners
are talking to who the other gun owners
are what gun shops I'm calling maybe to
buy firearms um that is a real problem
and right now there is absolutely no
basis for the Attorney General as a
practical matter um restricting them
from asking for this information when
they send a request over the common
carriers click their heels and hand it
to them on a silver
platter and that is simply not right
it's in my mind a Fourth Amendment
violation and the carriers are complicit
because they're afraid of government
regulation and so or abuse if you will
of Regulation passing a law like this is
going to give us a little bit of
protection and making the Attorney
General's office or their designate go
before in theory a neutral and detached
Magistrate that has to have an affidavit
signed under oath and so one of the
representatives that asked that this
would be lowering the standards
absolutely not this is protection I see
this as raising the
standards and I see this as making an
example that they cannot simply get
around the Constitution by laws like
this which is really what's been
happening and it's unfortunate and so
the bottom line is if they think
someone's breaking the law if they have
probable cause or any type of basis they
should be able to put it in an affidavit
where an officer has to sign under oath
under the pains and penalties of perjury
not just I think or maybe baby I have
disinformation chairman I have a
question the witness is over two
minutes out of
order you not recognize to speak please
don't interrupt the testimony of witness
uh although testimony for members of
public is limited to two minutes it is
within the discretion of the chair to
allow it to go beyond
that you are the first it's been like
that throughout the entire term you're
the first person member of this
committee to complain about this so
please if you wish to speak you must
raise your hand and be
recognized I apologize to the the member
of the public testifying may continue
your
testimony thank you chairman so I see
this as being more protective for
consumers and more protective in general
because the at I will be surprised if
the Attorney General on April 9th at the
conclusion of when the representatives
WR to no request truly responds with
complete information I think the
committee should look at what the
response is and then talk to the
criminal defense spyer and suggest that
um I'll be shocked if all the
information is given I think that what
you're going to see is the attorney
general is going to claim there's
ongoing investigations that this would
compromise
I don't believe that will be accurate
but I think that will be one of their
grounds for not giving all complete
information under 91a so I'd
respectfully say that even if a person
isn't a gun owner I don't care if you're
a dog owner or a whatever you are you
don't want your entire circle of friends
being identified by name and number and
being harassed your suspended we do have
to do testimony oh thank thank you I
apologize I'll wrap up I would
respectfully ask the committee to pass
this bill I think it's a good bill and
I'm happy to answer any questions and
thank you speaker or
chairman I want I want to thank thank
you for your testimony and if the chair
can inquire of a question uh and I want
to thank you in advance for taking my
question in regards to the the
communications of the the data that that
we're referencing uh my question is is
who owns that that data and I what I'm
getting at is I understand there's a
problem here
that my question is would a warrant be
the resolution that because the common
carrier is a is a third
party thank you thank you for your
question um the the common carrier is a
third
party and I can't say that I've seen
every cell phone or common carrier
agreement but I like everyone else have
switched carriers over the years every
carrier that I've ever signed the
agreement with nobody reads the
agreement except for geeky lawyers like
me and it provides that the carrier owns
the data at least the ones that I've
looked at and so I can't imagine that
all the others don't provide the same
thing but even though they own the data
and so you normally say well that's not
a Fourth Amendment violation when the
data is being coerced which essentially
is by the
AG the person doesn't even know their d
has been accessed and that's what's
really troubling because if I knew that
let's say Verizon gave my data up to the
AG I might switch to a different carrier
and I might want to know what had been
given to the AG and why and so they have
an incredible amount of data the other
thing is when private attorneys will
subp like for example I would subpoena
um phone records I do it all the time
it's amazing the the common carriers
will tell me oh we don't have it past 30
days or 60 days or whatever their
arbitrary limit is at a given time yet
if the cops go get it they can get it
for years back so the common carriers do
not treat defense attorneys the same way
they do the
prosecutors and that that's a that's a
problem and most clients you can't
afford the average client cannot afford
to litigate against Verizon or AT&T
they're they're a
monster you know thank you and and if I
may take my question if I may inquire of
a follow
question
so would would you believe or would you
agree that it's a a potential Fourth
Amendment violation to require the
common carriers to
surrender the information or the data
that without the requiring of a warrant
I mean I suppose AT&T or Verizon wanted
to decline the request made by the
there's they don't need a warrant they
they basically have to surrender it
they they do have to surrender it right
now and a lot of them are afraid not to
unfortunately the people in Black robes
because um AT&T is not a government
entity or the common carriers are not a
government entity they don't see it as a
Fourth Amendment violation I do but
here's what I remind people until heler
came down the black robes in this
country didn't say we had an individual
right to keep and bear arms it wasn't
until heler and McDonald that the court
recognize that right so courts are not
always right but un I agree that it is a
Fourth Amendment violation chairman but
do thank you again for taking my
question representative B you recognize
for a question thank you Mr chairman and
if I may also you know be recognized in
a minute for a followup but my first
question um attorney Dean is you've
already answered part of it that they
can subpoena my records or not subpoena
they can um the AG can request and get
my records or anybody's records from
carrier is there a way that I could find
if that has been done or is it a secret
I will never
know it is a secret um I would be
shocked if you're able to find that out
because law enforcement always puts this
Cav add in um that this is a law
enforcement matter and you could
compromise an investigation and blah
blah blah so I have had clients that we
know the records were obtained by law
enforcement because we got them in
Discovery and when they called their
carrier their carrier like we don't know
what you're talking about and all I
could think of is liar liar pants on
fire but you can't make them give you
that information so I would say I would
be shocked if you found
out thank you
followup Mr chairman representative you
are recognized for a followup question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my follow-up question um as I
read the bill it's it's obvious it's for
cell phones
landlines um you know Etc like that but
does it also include social media
Facebook in Google searches you know
would it incorporate
that thank you for your question
representative I think it would if it's
used from your smartphone because data
is data so in other words if if you take
most people's smartphone that I've ever
seen they have an internet connection on
it and they run all sorts of searches
through that phone and it's all through
your phone service that that is run so I
cannot imagine that it wouldn't include
that I can't say how each um company
keeps their data but I cannot imagine it
wouldn't be part and parcel of that and
so for example you take someone like
like me depending on what case I'm
working on there is a two-year period
where I did a lot of research on hand
grenades now hand grenades if you file a
form four are perfectly lawful to own in
my case I was doing research on them
because of a case not because I wanted
to do anything illegal but I do through
intellectual curiosity and through my
practice a lot of searches that someone
may take umage at her suggest oh she
must be looking to break the
law
you thank
you see seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for for her testimony
thank you for having me there is a
member of the public with a hand raised
uh it's only a phone number so just
please identify yourself for the record
by stating your full name where you're
from and whether you're testifying in
support or in opposition to House Bill
good
morning
morning uh this is Jay simpin 20 cabit
Drive nashille New
Hampshire uh I hope this bill will be
enacted and thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony uh I'm an international
economic consultant uh so I think of
data as plural not a singular key point
is this data are
lethal the idea that data and data
security is about privacy is simply
wrong a recent example from The Wider
World early in January 19 uh
2020 an Iranian General arrived at the
airport in Bagdad Iraq
he w got into his car to leave and was
then killed by two drone fired missiles
what has this to do with common carriers
in New Hampshire it is this the only
thing that the United States needed to
know was where that Iranian General
would be and when he would be there our
telephones re Smartphones at any rate
regularly ping
cell towers so that if a call comes in
it will be clear how it should be
routed that information called cell site
lator
information is for individuals the
equivalent of law enforcement putting a
GPS device on a vehicle to track it in
order to put such a device on a vehicle
law enforcement have to get a search
warrant why because they are seeking
information that is private about a
person so they have to go to a judge or
a magistrate show that they have
probable cause to need to imp place a
GPS cracking device on a vehicle and if
the judge or magistrate is persuaded
that probable cause has been shown
basically the warrant issues and the
device can be lawfully imp placed and
the person
tracked as things now stand every one of
us carries with us a GPS tracking device
it's called a
smartphone and unless we turn it off so
it cannot ping cell towers those who
have
csli cell site locator information which
all the carriers necessarily have and
have to have can provide a map of where
we get go and it's a fairly precise map
not down to the nearest Foot but if a
crime were committed uh it would tell
law enforcement that we were pretty
close to where that crime was committed
so in short the data that this bill
would protect by requiring law
enforcement to get a warrant in order to
access the data is simply
vital and there should really not be or
there should not need to be discussion
as to the necessity of enacting this
bill if law enforcement needs a warrant
to imp place a GPS tracker on a vehicle
they should need to get a warrant to get
the
information about our smartphone usage
it's really cut and dried as the British
say when something is obvious it is
quote a no-brainer end quote uh thank
you Mr chairman and members of the
questions seeing No Hands raised I want
to thank the witness for his
testimony if there any members of the
public who are in attend attendance that
wish to testify that have not testified
already please raise your hand at this
time
seeing No Hands raised at this time the
public we will close the public hearing
on House Bill
[Music]
honors on host Bill uh 539 there were
nine people who signed in in support uh
no one signed in in opposition and two
neutral this time we are opening the
public hearing on House Bill 612
relative to the penalty for overtaking a
school
tersi represent Colley is now present
room representative you're
recognized
morning thank you for having me my name
is Laura tersi and I represent Hillsboro
35 which is NASA's Ward 8 today I'm
presenting to you for your consideration
HB 612 FN relative to the penalty for
overtaking a school bus a little history
on how this bill came
about back in 2018 there were a number
of well publicized accidents involving
school buses and in 2019 house trans
Transportation received three different
bills from both sides of the aisle that
were filed to increase the penalty for
overtaking a
bus the bills either increased the fines
suspended the driver's license or were a
combination of both we retained the
bills and our full committee worked
together in a bipartisan collaboration
to review and develop one that we all
agreed with today's Bill House Bill 612
is the exact same wording as House Bill
626 that passed the Full House last
January let me walk you through the
changes to the
statute the current fine for a
first-time offense is
$150 and this bill increases it to
$250 most violations are issued to
firsttime offenders and I imagine it's
often a wakeup call and a lesson learned
in 2019 the department of safety issued
119 citations for firsttime violations
and one for a subsequent off
in 2020 with far fewer buses on the
roads due to the pandemic there were
only 38 firsttime violations however
there was still one citation issued for
a subsequent
offense for subsequent offenses the
current statute has arranged for a fine
of $250 to
$1,000 we heard testimony from the
Department that having a range is
problematic and it's preferable to have
one set fine we set that new fine for a
subsequent offense at $500 plus penalty
assessment which is not currently
included in the
statute regarding a suspension of
license we changed the word may to shall
to ensure an automatic loss of driving
privilege for 30 days again the
department stated a preference for
definitive wording as opposed to leaving
the suspension open as a
possibility the threat of an automatic
loss of license would hopefully be a
strong deterrent for the driver who
receives Citation for the First
Defense finally regarding the fiscal
note of
$155,000 I reached out to the department
to confirm that this is the blanket
fiscal note that they give to bills that
would require an update to the uniform
fine schedule and reprogramming of their
systems with the effective date of
January 1 it can be assumed that all
updates for the year would occur at once
and they would be able to consolidate
all of the changes and charges at that
time in conclusion HB 612 tightens up
the wording of the existing statute
while increasing the fine moderately for
the first offense and a mandatory 30-day
loss of license for repeat offenders I
believe these changes speak to the
seriousness of the violation without
being overly burdensome for the
firsttime offender who truly does make a
mistake in passing a school bus at the
same time one accident is far too many
and I believe the penalty needs to be
updated to send a strong message about
the safety of our children I believe
representatives from the Department of
Safety will make themselves available
after my testimony but I'm happy to take
have representative G you recognized
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
in 20120 to 38 First cases is that just
National or is that
Statewide thank you for the question
that's Statewide I got those numbers
from the Department of Safety
directly thank you
representative Muse you
recognized yes thank you for taking my
question um in the in the bill uh you
for or the bill for subsequent offenses
um uh cites a $500 plus penalty
assessment um what is a penalty
assessment in in terms of this
particular
Bill thank you for the question
representative Muse um I may defer for
the legal uh definition to someone from
the Department safety but what I
understand is it's a um additional fine
that's issued it's a percentage um of
the uh the fine that is added on um for
the Violator and as you can see for the
first time offense in the statute it's
already listed there the penalty
assessment I believe for the secondary
offense it was a um an Omission um that
should have been included but um again I
would defer I think um M Britney shoot
from the Department of safety may be
willing to answer that question if she's
you seeing no further hands raised
representative I want to thank you for
your testimony thank you so very much
day Mr chairman I do not see any hands
yeah this I know representative abson is
present he's on the list as well oh 's a
couple hands Mr any members of the
public who are present and that are in
attendance that wish to testify please
raise your hand this time the chair now
recognizes representative Max Abramson
and me to the members of the public we
uh with the exception of the
representative introduces the bill we
are limiting testimonies to two minutes
per
witness uh can you folks hear me yes we
can hear you uh all right I'm
representative Max Abramson I'll try to
keep my um statements down to two
minutes um I do support the bill and I I
submitted an amendment uh 443 H uh which
would quadruple speeding fines while
someone is uh overtaking a a school bus
or passing a school bus um my reasoning
for supporting the bill um and and the
reason I submitted an amendment is the
fines actually seem uh pretty slight
this uh driving past a a school bus
that's loading and offloading children
and especially if people are driving at
very high speed which they they often
tend to do is that if you compare this
to drinking and driving this if
somebody's driving you know down a a
dark road somewhere this is many many
times more dangerous than drinking and
driving this is much more dangerous than
uh somebody shooting some fireworks off
into a residential neighborhood or or or
even firing a gun into the forest or
something this is this is uh uh the
statistics on hitting a an adult if you
if you're driving a car and you hit you
hit an adult pedestrian um their chances
of surviving um at 15 miles an hour at
the time of impact are about 85 to 90%
if you hit them at 25 miles per hour
that uh drops down to 55% and if you hit
them at 35 miles an hour they're
American and European studies that show
the survival rate drops down to about 10
or 15% and most civil engineers and and
safety experts uh admit that um at
speeds higher than that your chances of
of survival if you get hit at a speed
higher than that are are are almost none
so when a school bus stops it's almost
certain and they put the stop sign out
it's almost certain that there are going
to be children going across the road
it's almost a
certainty and so somebody speeding past
a bus their chances of hitting a child
are very very high and that child
doesn't have any realistic opportunity
to move out of the way the visibility
very ports why we have the stop sign up
um and there's nothing that the school
bus driver can do so I think that the
bill is necessary and I also think that
the amendment is necessary quadrupling
the speeding fines to deter people from
flying uh past at very high speeds there
are some people who are driving I've
been told 70 miles an hour but I I have
I have a hard time believing that but
even if somebody's doing 45 or 55 miles
an hour past a school bus I think that's
just
uh that's borderline felony
endangerment thank thank you
[Music]
representative see no hands raised
representative I want to thank you for
your
testimony thank
you well excuse me sorry representative
TR a question of the chair yes um do we
have anyone from
DMV maybe by the name of Chris will be
testifying you
know I don't see anyone in attendance
with that name or anyone on the list
there is Mr chairman uh Miss shoot uh is
representing DMB is my
recollection and Sergeant Kelby uh has
also addressed this issue before
represent again seeing no uh questions
for the witness restive 8% is excused at
this time the chair will recognize
Britney
sh good member my name good morning my
name is Britney Shu and I am a
representative of financial
responsibility from the Division of
Motor Vehicles we appreciate the work
that has been done on this bill and as
representative uh tersi pointed out um
it gives more definite um suspension
time and fees um with that I happy to
questions representative true you
recognize thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my
offenders um could you give us an idea
of how many repeat offenders do not lose
thank you for your
question repeat offenders I cannot speak
to how many have been
suspended I can definitely find that
you representative PR I have a question
uh how is the person caught doing
this
I'm sorry can you repeat your
question question how is how was the
up you know the
process you know who called who turns it
in I believe thank you for your question
um when a person passes a school bus I
believe it would be the bus driver of
the vehicle or any um participants
witnessed um anyone that's witnessed the
actions they contact the local police
department and I believe um that is how
that is
handled they're required to write a
letter you think that's true bus driver
required to write a letter St they
saw thank you for your
question if Sergeant Kelby is on this he
may be able to speak to the process
required by law enforcement to take the
appropriate action and how the citation
would be issued to the individual who um
you if I may I believe there was a
question in regards to penalty
assessment the penalty assessment
pursuant to RSA 106
L10 is it's a penalty of $2 or 24%
whichever is graded and is added to the
fine that is set in the uniform time
schedule
representative gather can you just
repeat what was said yes thank you for
your question the penalty assessment
is penalty of $2 or 24% whichever is
greater and it is applied to the
statutory
10 thank you seeing no further hands
raised the witness is excused I want to
thank you again for your testimony at
this time the chair recognizes Sergeant
Christopher
Kelby
hello
hello I apologize for uh I I just uh
I've been having some technical issues
with my computer and as representative
tersi was concluding Our Testimony I was
finally able to get in um to address the
question about um who is the complainant
on a violation uh for passing a school
bus um the school bus driver or the
statute actually says any witness um the
school bus driver would would typically
be the uh the complainant on on such a
violation of course the problem being
that the school bus driver is often uh
you know focused on the kids getting on
and off the bus um and you know dealing
with the kids that are on the bus so a
lot of times those uh complaints uh
can't be um prosecuted because we we
can't get a good statement from the
times
representative Conley you recognized
thank you Mr chairman thank you
Sergeant um in your experience do higher
fines tend to lead to changes in
Behavior like has been suggested might
pass yeah yeah I I I think that's uh you
know I mean you know if you're asking my
personal experience or my uh guess I
should say I would say Yes um um knowing
that it's going to cost you x amount of
money if you're speeding uh in a
particular area is probably going to
make people slow down a little more
often um the the the the possibility of
a suspended license is is certainly
going to um you know increase
that that I call it survivability I know
in Maine they have criminal speed uh
there's a there's an assumption by a lot
of Us in New Hampshire that we have
criminal speed uh we don't um you know
obviously we have reckless driving but
the the knowledge that criminal speed is
out there and and people can be arrested
for you know for a particular speed
limit like in Maine does does affect uh
driving representative con you recognize
for a followup question thank you Mr
chairman and Sergeant um did I
understand correctly a moment ago you
say that um some uh likely cases of
passing the school bus illegally are not
actually prosecuted as such might
suggest that the number of times this
occurs would be more than the data uh of
people who are penalized for this
offense would
suggest thank you representative Kinley
and and that's not a guess um we do um
Operation Safe stop uh we didn't do it
last year because of coid and it's a new
initiative that uh School Bus industry
um initiated with Department of Safety
um and the
saus and we're reporting um you know
many many many times more violations of
passing school buses than are than are
prosecuted that's factual information we
take those stats and I apologize I don't
have those stats I wasn't prepared to
answer question like that I can
certainly uh look to my my Trooper
that's in charge of people
transportation to to obtain that
information but the last the year before
last um when we had operation saf stop
we had you know I think we issued maybe
three or four summonses throughout the
state um but but that was just a like a
tiny tiny tiny percentage of the
reported violations that occurred during
that particular day uh that that we had
going representative CR I have a
question um in my area we have a large
bus company we have one driver that
writes a letter DMV almost every month
about somebody passing them and then we
have other bus drivers that never have
written a letter for that violation ever
and they've and they've been bus drivers
for years you think that speaks to the
accuracy of the bus drivers in trying to
prosecut
say no I don't um and thank you for the
question
you you know uh being a cop's not easy
and being aware of all the laws that we
we have to be familiar with isn't easy
as well and um going to court isn't easy
you know we you know we we we present
cases often and they're thrown out um
but educating law
enforcement um as to the process under
26554 has always been um really hard for
Department of Safety people
Transportation unit um a lot of times
police officers are not
aware that the um that the uh the law
speaks to a school bus
driver um being able to be the you know
the mechanism for legal action to take
place now
consequently uh it's also imperative
that the complainant is able to
identify um the vehicle that that uh
passed it and again this is the problem
you know you we'll we'll we don't the uh
Office of Pupil Transportation does not
get a lot of these letters um what we
typically do and I've done this in the
past is I I I'll get a call to to my
trooper that runs that program and I'll
be filling in for whatever the case may
be and I'll have a bus driver I rate
that they had a vehicle pass them and my
question is have you did you get the
license plate well I didn't okay do you
have a camera on the bus well we don't
um okay can you describe the vehicle
well it was green there's there's not a
lot we can do with that
unfortunately um so so a lot of times
we'll get these complaints that
unfortunately just aren't um up to Snuff
for us to be able to do anything with
but also
um but also
uh getting getting off track
here the getting that complaint with the
accurate information to the police
officer is is imperative but we also
don't enforce laws in Comm commun you
know these traffic laws in most
communities we refer these to the police
department we will get calls from
concerned bus drivers that the the local
police department isn't you know isn't
issuing a summons based on their
complaint we've called police officers
uh you know police Chiefs from the
community and explain to them that the
the driver of the school bus under
statutory law is essentially the
complainant for that uh summon uh police
officers are not used to that because we
don't normally um there's a most cases
we can't use a a complaint from a third
party to to prosecute so we're we have
it drilled in our heads that you know we
can't rely on on a statement without a
complaint affidavit War War to support
it after an investigation but this is
one that says oh by the way you don't
need it the the school bus driver is
sufficient so education to the police
department is essential um reminding
police officers that they have the
authority to do this uh continuing with
Operation Safe stop educates our police
officers too to this uh to this uh you
know to this law um but you know a lot
of these complaints that do go to the
DMV uh they don't make it to us but a
lot of times when they do make it to the
prosecute hope I hope that answered your
question thank
you thank you for that representative
Muse you recognized for a
question thank you for taking my
question um uh you raised an issue that
I was curious about I'm wondering how
common uh cameras are on school buses in
New
Hampshire um
thank you for your question they're not
statutorily mandated um and the problem
of course is that uh well typically the
cameras that are on school buses are
inside facing um cameras and they're
also owned or contracted by the SAU the
school bus company doesn't actually own
the the rights to that uh digital
information uh typically we'll have a uh
complaint of a school bus driver come in
like Behavior type issue we'll find out
if they have a uh a camera on board and
then we'll petition the school
department the SAU if we can gather that
information um some school some school
bus services uh like uh Manchester
Transit Authority have 365 degree
cameras inside and outside um making you
know making a um making a violation re
really easy for a police officer to to
bring forward onal half of the the
school bus driver but those are very
rare uh we we don't have a lot of
cameras out there um interior cameras
are are more common but they're not
required by the
state
follow represent M you were recognized
for a followup question so so knowing
that Manchester has um that type of
equipment already on their school buses
do they have a a higher rate of
prosecutions for this
offense
thanks for your followup question of
course that's one I have no idea about I
I could tell you the the year before
last um when we were doing safe stop we
were actually in Manchester and about an
hour after the um the uh the the the
operation started our first summons
issued was by Manchester uh which was
great um but I I I think we only had
like maybe three summonses issued that
day but one of them was man TR I think
Portsmouth was another one um I but I
can't answer that question without I
really don't know the answer that
you see see no further hands raised I
want to thank thank the witness for his
testimony thank
you any members of the public who are in
attendance that wish to testify that
have not testified already please raise
your
hand
the chair now recognizes Katherine
[Music]
Cooper U thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee this is
Katherine Cooper here testifying today
in opposition to this bill on behalf of
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers um our
opposition is fairly simple we believe
that you should leave the discretion for
punishment of the bulk of offenses to
prosecutors and judges so that they can
evaluate the facts and circumstances of
each case um you know I can tell you
quite a few stories having represented
people on charges like this where um it
would have been significantly unjust to
punish them um at a higher rate and to
have these automatic fines and license
suspensions in fact one of the cases
that I had involved an actual bus driver
who was charged with passing a school
bus um at a school because the
dispatcher had told her she was in her
personal car still go around them and go
move the other bus so the police officer
who was on site saw this car um go past
the school bus with the stop sign on and
you know he kind of went ballistic on
her and um she ended up charged by the
time we were able to get to court
everything was calmed down we explained
the circumstances the dispatcher
explained um the charge ended up being
placed on file without a finding because
the police officer was still really
angry and refused to let the prosecutor
completely drop it but you know that
would have been a situation where we
have someone who actually works there
fully understands what's going on and
the people who are actually watching the
safety of the children were all in the
loop and knew that the kids were on the
bus and this lady just had to go past to
move the other bus um anyway so that's
just one example the fact that we need
to give the people who are involved in
actual cases the ability and the
authority to put into place appropriate
sanctions um for the facts and
circumstances of each
case um I'd also like to point out the
fact that in the extreme cases for
example where someone is speeding um
past a school bus and really endangering
someone they're likely to also be
charged with Reckless operation or
another higher level driving offense so
um there are plenty of tools there to
make higher sanctions and get license
suspensions for people who are really uh
behaving in a dangerous fashion in this
way so um I would encourage the
you thank you M M Cooper for your
testimony the chair May inquire question
and I will thank you in advance for
taking my
question uh did I understand your
testimony correctly did did you testify
that the the district attorney or the
County Attorney would not drop the
charge because the police officer
wouldn't let them if I heard that
correctly
or yeah the police officer felt very
strongly that because the person was
technically guilty of that charge they
didn't want it to just be dropped so it
ended up being placed on file without a
f
thank you representative B you recognize
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my testimony uh so from what I'm
hearing is because I see in the bill on
line six it says that the director shall
if this passes before current law is
made so if I'm hearing you correctly you
believe that the May should stand so
that way the judge has discretion on yes
this is a bad person that was a dummy
that passed a bus or this was an honest
mistake is that what I'm hearing it
exactly representative B that's exactly
our position you should keep this keep
the discretion with the prosecutor to
request it and the judge to um put a
suspension in place if it is indeed
appropriate in any given
that
thank you seeing seeing no further hands
raised the witness is excusable and
thank you again for your testimony thank
much see no members of the public with
their hand raised at this
time we
will represent M before we close want to
honors yes on um uh on HB 612 we we had
nine people sign in in support and we
opposition thank you representative M at
this time we will close the public
stre
just have the members stay everyone
heads up we're gonna open an executive
seats
yeah we're going to do that once it's
over thank you Mr chairman say new rules
proper
at this time we will reopen the the
executive session on House
Bill
576 relative to the victim's
compensation
fund
Wednesday and I believe represent want
recognized yes Mr chairman I would like
to
be open up house 576 consideration
to is there a second to that motion for
consideration
second
second just just for the members that
are participating remotely before
in regards to house
rules a member has to be in their seat
when a matter is put the question once
the question is put if you're not in
your
seat you're not ask the rules don't
permit that member to return to the seat
it's also the reverse if you're in your
seat the members not actually committed
to
leave ordinary circumstances this is a
very clear rule when we're all sitting
in the room together however when
members are participating remotely
it can be a little more
chall but the members that are not
physically in the room I will say that
every time
I remove the
question I always say seeing no fur the
hands raised
then matter the
question if you're not if your camera is
not
on going forward the chair is not going
to consider that member be in their
seat I would say for the members
participating
remotely it is a good practice leave
your camera on during the exec
session uh I I don't I don't see that
being a very difficult T to a rule to
comply with so I would ask that all
members I do do my best to make sure
there are members moving around in the
physical room I'm sure the
representative from do knows that I try
to accommodate people schedule
I don't try to take advantage of the
fact that someone's simply standing you
know for a minute and then try to rule
them not in their seat but at the same
time we do need to keep things moving
and if we're all going to participate in
the executive
session I would assume that if if the
members engaged that that camera would
be on and I believe that's also just
from a fairness perspective it's for the
members of the public it's it's
appreciated so representative bden I see
the cameras on on I am we're about to
move the question but I would I would
ask all members have their cameras on if
they're not on although that member's
name will be called their vote will not
be
yes but it would be good practice to
Simply leave the I would recommend the
members leave the cameras on so there's
no
misunderstanding
seeing No Hands
raised the matter will now be put
question if you in favor of the motion
for consideration please say yay if you
opposed please say
nay clerk can not call the
role Vice chairman Welch I
representative Bert yes representative
Spain
green representa Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
CRA yes representative morston yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harry
gffr yes rep representative Bixby
yes representative
oarn
yes representative Bard n
yes representative Muse yes
representative
Newman
yes representative golden yes
representative Conley yes representative
Klein Knight yes representative Bradley
yes
chairman chair votes yes Mr chair the
vote is
d
by a vote of 20 Y and zero Nays the
passed at this
time recognizing representative VES for
to make a motion about to
pass Mr i' like to make a motion about
to pass for house
576 I'll
second that motion of to pass has been
seconded by representative gaff
motion chair I would
um represent to speak on
it you y you yield your thank you that
was the word I to
represent um I believe that we received
um additional information on this over
the uh I guess over the weekend from
letting us know uh where the money comes
from with the AG off so with that said
pass see no further hands
raised matter will now be put the
question CL Now call the rooll if you're
in favor the motion of V to pass please
say yay if you oppose please say n
Vice chairman wels I representative B
yes representative Spain yes
representative
green representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative
true representative Pratt yes
representative Marson yes Clark votes
yes representative Harry cfre yes
representative
pantus I'm representative vix before uh
subing in for her
yes representative o'n yes
representative
B yes representative Muse
yes representative Newman
yes representative
bden yes representative Conley yes
representative Knight yes represent
Senator Bradley yes chairman the chair
votes yes Mr chairman the vote is 19 yay
zero nay I voted 19 Y and zero Nays the
motion about to pass
consent represent you majority report
yes
[Music]
at this time we will now close the
executive session on House Bill
576 just got to have a question who was
missing other in
greenes representative True Green and
true
a
mic
representative I am representative darl
abis and I am I represent Rockham County
District 8 and I both house 347 and
house
179 thank
you I'll start with House Bill
347 this bill was filed last year and I
believe it passed manly in
transportation and however it was either
tabled or did not make it out of the
Senate due to the co 19
pandemic what this what this bill would
essentially do if someone is convicted
of driving with a suspended license what
would happen is the for the purposes of
considering whether it's a subsequent
offense the in the state of New
Hampshire they only consider the a
conviction previously in New
Hampshire when this when this issue was
brought to my attention the majority
overwhelming majority of Motor Vehicle
infractions or Motor Vehicle Laws
whether they're infractions or amount to
a criminal
offense they take into
consideration reasonably equivalent
offenses and other jurisdictions very
common with drunk driving
convictions whether it's offensive with
speeding or whatnot this seemed to be
the only offense that we could that was
on the on record that did not take into
consideration an out of state conviction
so what this would do it was believ that
this was more oversight when the law was
uh passed as opposed to anything else so
this was intended specifically
to uh make this consistent with the
laws then in respect to House Bill
[Applause]
involves offering you know a negligent
homicide and it references RSA 630 col 3
an aggravated or an aggravated Defence
while driving well
intoxicated basically this involves a
vehicular
homicide what it would do is that it
would right now A A it would be
considered class a felony but it's
also the penalty is basically seven
years it can be increase depending on
some other circumstances but what this
would do it would added to a minimum
sentence of 10 years as opposed to right
now with with the lighter sentence for
it also takes in consideration if the
negligent homicide was a result of a
driver who had prior convictions of
drunk driving and it takes into
consideration whether they had one
previous conviction or they had two
prior convictions I will say that drunk
driving is a problem in all 50 states
and it can continues to be a problem
it's not just operating under the
influence of alcohol it's also operating
under the influence of any drugs or
substance that would impair one's
ability to
drive it's something that it's a hazard
that's that's throughout the state that
that and I would say that someone who's
committed this
offense and then is already been
convicted of it and then to commit the
offense again resulting in in a
homicide uh is a terrible tragedy that
could be avoided but
unfortunately uh this this is intended
to really raise raise the the offense uh
this bill was actually filed last term
uh it was uh Senate Bill
743 uh was filed by Senator felus uh it
did pass in the Senate however it was
tabled as a result of the co 19
pandemic uh this was a bill that I uh
came across really by by Fate just due
to the title in did because it had a
similar title to a bill that was in our
committee last year even though the two
bills were very
different I but I signed in support of
the bill and I supported the concept and
I I certainly supported what uh the
motivation behind this bill uh the bill
is drafted uh which that was Senate Bill
743 would had a title called naming it
Tyler Shaw's law I did not include that
name in the this bill but I there is an
amendment that is proposed that that has
been prepared that would add that and
sadly Mr sh was killed by a drunk driver
on April 30th of
and Tyler was driving on a logging Hill
Road
in and at the end of the ex a drunk
driver blew through a stops line at 60
miles an hour and subsequently hit
and caused the caus him to pass away
from from the accident uh the driver of
that vehicle had two prior uh DUI
convictions UL uh they were 11 years
apart but the driver did have two
convictions the perpetrator got a
sentence of six to 12
years it was my opinion just and I sat
and listened to the testimony uh from
the senator last year when the bill was
introduced in the Senate and uh I agreed
that it really did show a gap in the law
that we would need some enhancement in
the sentences regarding aggravated DUIs
or negligent
homicide uh for someone who is arrested
and convicted of having a DUI as part of
the U often the if they are convicted
the post trial probation there's often
educational classes and awareness that
person would go through although it's
it's presumed that someone anyone who's
licensed to drive knows the risk and
dangers of uh drunk driving or driving
while
impaired uh someone who's been already
convicted of a of this offense has been
re-educated on that so it would be uh in
my opinion less acceptable for this to
time so there's different circumstances
that can that can invoke an elevated
offense uh one of them would be the
blood alcohol content being double the
legal limit uh so right now it's
08 uh so if you your blood alcohol
content was 0.16 at the time of the
accident that would be an uh a fence
that can make it an aggravated
offence I will say that uh this is this
is a bill that's intended to not only
raise awareness but it's also intended
to try to deter the activity of driving
um under the influence of alcohol and I
think it's particularly important to
deter repeat offenders because uh any
anytime someone gets behind the wheel
while impaired they run the risk of uh
causing harm to someone in this in this
way and it's always a dangerous act so I
would hope that this bill is considered
uh given consideration and it's t the
pass I will yield any questions for when
then
there Mr chairman I just asked her to
right
morning good morning would you uh let us
know which bill you are addressing
whether I'm addressing Bill
179 thank you
make
good morning my name is Beth Shaw and I
support Bill
179 which would also be known as Tyler
Shaw's law Tyler Shaw is my
son Tyler was only 20 years old when he
was killed by a drunk driver in
2018 sadly the tragic crash that killed
my son would Mark the third DUI
conviction of the man that killed
him I ask each of you to to consider
this question if your son daughter
spouse or parent were senselessly
brutally murdered by a person whose
driving record is littered with drunk
driving
convictions would you feel six years in
prison is an adequate penalty for the
one it is important for you to know the
history of the drunk driver Joseph
Leonard Jr that killed Tyler it is the
backbone of this
bill Mr Leonard's first DUI conviction
was at the age of
17 his second DUI conviction involved a
single car accident with a blood alcohol
of
0.24 along with an admission that he
took countless prescription pills before
getting behind the
wheel he was sentenced to 12 months in
prison all of which was suspended by a
New Hampshire
judge he was also required to have an
interlock installed in his
car five months after his interlock was
installed he blew a 0.16 into his
Interlock in November of
2017 his interlock was removed from his
vehicle a mere six months after his
interlock was removed he killed my
son Mr Leonard was not coming home from
a bar the night he killed Tyler he was
coming directly from
work he worked in Lebanon and he lived
in Dairy he knew he had a two-hour Drive
ahead of him yet he chose to drink
enough during his workday to put his
blood alcohol at 016 at the time of the
crash his history of drinking and
driving endangering countless lives of
New Hampshire residents is
horrifying what I find equally
horrifying is the Miss opportunities by
new New Hampshire courts to hold Mr
Leonard accountable for his drunk
driving
convictions after all the goal of
sentencing is to send a clear message of
deterrence and
Rehabilitation however when New
Hampshire courts allow a defense lawyer
to successfully plead down the charges
to a slap on the wrist that opportunity
is
lost I will always wonder if Mr Leonard
had served some time anytime from his
second conv ition would it have changed
his
behavior more importantly for me would
my son be alive
today to reinforce the fact that current
negligent homicide penalties are
inadequate is to compare them to other
penalties of crimes none of which
resulted in death in 2019 and 2020 the
following sentences were handed down in
New Hampshire
courtrooms a molten Boro man was
sentenced to 15 to 30 years for
rape a Laconia man was sentenced to five
years for
robbery a Manchester man was sentenced
to 16 and a half years for assaulting
and robbing someone assisting a federal
agent a Manchester man was sentenced to
an 11-year prison sentence for federal
marijuana
convictions a gtown man was sentenced to
seven and a half years for possession of
a controlled drug and possession of a
controlled drug with the intent to sell
or
dispense and in 2020 a Manchester man
was sentenced to 10 years for possessing
a firearm after a felony
conviction as terrible those as those
crimes are none of those crimes resulted
in death yet the sentences are longer
than that of negligent
homicide there has been some criticism
of this bill that an enhanced sentence
is not going to deter people from from
driving drunk or solve the underlying
problem that is not the purpose of Bill
179 the purpose is to adequately and
appropriately sentence habitual
offenders who take the life of an
innocent
victim a drunk driver with multiple
convictions deserves the enhancements
articulated in this
bill as a mother who has made her way
through the criminal justice system
because a young s son was killed by a
drunk driver I am urging you to support
this bill help protect New Hampshire
residents and honor those lives that
were senselessly taken by a drunk
driver as a state New Hampshire needs to
step up and strengthen the drunk driving
laws too many innocent victims are dying
on New Hampshire
roads you won't see change unless you
make change and if this bill could save
thank you for your time I appreciate
your
consideration thank
M there no questions from the
committee we will
[Music]
shoot good morning members of the
committee I believe I checked that I did
not have any testimony but I am here
questions you you be limited to a two
minute testimony and be helpful if you
uh State up front which bill you are
addressing and whether you support or
oppose make
Contin who does she represent I think
she's
I'm with the Department of Safety
Division of Motor Vehicles and we are
neutral on this I am here um as if any
questions had come up if I could
question has a question thank you for
taking my question and being here for
that question um the last speaker of
that lost her son
said that the person
that had the inter I'm not sure what it
is it's a system in your
truck it blew he got into the truck to
1.6 I'm assuming the
system you know the whole system you
know our court system and everything
else failed us at that point um could
you
explain normally what happens and why it
didn't happen in this case that he blew
a 1.6 and didn't show up at his door
yard in like three seconds to say what's
going
on thank you for your question an
ignition interlock device is a device in
which an individual would provide a
breast sample there
at the set point the vehicle should not
start um I'm not quite sure if Miss Shaw
had articulated that the device was
removed um prior to to that accident
with the 0.16 so therefore there
wouldn't have been a device in the
vehicle to prevent the vehicle from
being started but what a device is
supposed to do is prohibit the start of
a vehicle when the breath alcohol
content has reached the set
point all right thank you and Mr
chairman a followup yes follow up and
and well thank you for taking my second
question so how she did mention that you
know five months later I believe it was
that she said that U it was
removed how would that happen if you
blow a
1.6 that in you're trying to drive I'm
assuming somebody's
notified um how would that interlocked
system be removed five months later with
that behavior you know where did the
system go wrong so we could try to fix
it other than just this Bill thank you
for your follow-up question if the
device was removed from the vehicle it
would have been that the individual
required to have it has met their
retention period for that um if they
have a
12-month requirement they can have a
six- month requirement the requirement
can be extended due to multiple
violations if Mr Leonard had met the
point to which he um the that 12 months
so we'll say for an instance in this
conversation that he was required to
have for 12 months on the day after the
12th month he would request for Motor
Vehicles a review of the record and if
there's nothing that is egregious or any
item there that would keep the device in
the vehicle which would ultimately be
referred to the Bureau of hearings to
have a hearing with that individual then
the device is removed from the
vehicle all right I understand now thank
you for helping me with that
absolutely is there any other question
from the committee I
[Music]
question yes Mr chairman thank thank you
and thank you for taking my question and
this is just more of a clarification on
what you just told representative Bert
so you have an interlock device and five
months prior the person blew a a value
that would exceed the law to start the
vehicle and the vehicle didn't start
when they reach the time limit on the
interlock device is that record of of um
each um event where they blew into the
inter device is that recorded in
reviewed or when you said that they
review the record they review the uh
violation record thank you for your
question when an individual ref device
removed from their vehicle the ignition
interlock coordinator does a review of
the violation logs all the violation
logs are kept by the provider so there's
monitoring and there's violations if
there's violations that are consistent
with referring the individual to a
hearing the then those uh violation are
forwarded to the New Hampshire hearings
Bureau who then conducts um a hearing
with the defendant to determine whether
the device needs to stay in the vehicle
and be extended I hope that answered
your
question followup Mr chairman we have a
followup yeah in the in the instances
that you said that the uh what was
reviewed I guess more
specifically if if in fact that 1.6 was
on the device would the person person
have reviewed the information on the
device and would a VI uh an amount
greater than the than
point8 um be a reason for them not to
remove the device thank you for your
question when the ignition interlock
coordinator reviews the reports of the
ignition interlock device uh 08
violations are sent to hearings for
are there any other questions from the
committee representative Pratt represent
Pratt has a question yes I have a
question uh if you would the interlock
uh system the Ignition Interlock system
has been one designed for drugs yet or
just alcohol thank you for your
questions currently the ignition
interlock device is for the breath
alcohol content and would serve for
alcohol thank
you
Wallace has a question thank you Mr
chairman not not a question but for the
record and a licensed and certified
interlock installer for Commonwealth of
Massachusetts for multiple years if
committee has any questions that be more
than Happ to feel that good years of
experience
this you will be useful during the
so know chairman um I do see a
representative
night
oh
night U thank you chairman thanks for
taking my question how many second
offender of how do we have any on on
record how many second offenders for
year thank you for your question I do
not have the information available but I
can certainly look into that for you and
circle back
followup yes forther
question um can you further elaborate on
this thank you for the
followup yes I do not have a
response thank
you all right further
questions see none the witnesses excuse
here
CCO good morning Mr chair I was here
viewing I didn't sign up to speak but I
am happy to answer any questions and
while miss Sho was testifying I did look
into some of our hearing records
pertaining to that individual Mr
Leonard
are there any
uh questions by the
committee Mr chairman what what record
did he look
up you know the DWI case yeah the one
that
uh yes I I looked up our hearing records
for interlock extension and I do have a
hearing report in front of me for what
looks
like a violation hearing that we held
based on a
0.65
BAC that had occurred on September 23rd
2016 so I believe that may have been the
incident that mhaw was referring to so I
can tell you what the department did in
that particular
case I would have a question repres a
question thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for looking that up because I
you know I'm just at a loss of why this
happened so if you wouldn't mind
explaining why he was allowed to blow a
1.65 and then 5 months
later have his Interlock system removed
out of the
vehicle yeah looking at we held a
hearing on November 10th 2016 for an
interlock extension because if someone
is not able to start their car based on
an elevated BAC the report goes from the
interlock provider to the Department of
Motor Vehicles who then forwards it to
us I'm the person generally who reviews
the violation reports and recommends
what to be scheduled for hearings so
this document was reviewed it was
recommended hearing that was held on
November 10th
2016 and there was an order extending
the interlock device based on that
0.165 it was for a per period of six
months I mean in retrospect we can look
at was a six-month suspension long
enough in retrospect it probably was not
but that was the action that the
department took a hearings examiner did
look at it and did extend the device six
extra
months in a followup Mr chairman yes
have a follow thank you Mr chairman uh
from what I understand uh and please
correct me if I misunderstood it was
removed five months later you know how
would that
happen well I would have to look at when
the removal date was but according to
this I'm looking at the hearing
report and it was
months so that would put it into July
extension any further questions for the
committee representative nman has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question the six-month
limitation on the extension of an
interlock device is that a rule or is
that an RSA that that uh is that a
maximum limit or is it something else no
no for each and that is that is a lesser
for each extension it could be up to a
year extension so that's why I say in
retrospect extending it for six
months if we had it to do over again
maybe we would do it differently but it
it can be up to a year so the hearings
examiner could do it up to a year for
each test over the 0.025
BAC thank you very much you're
committee have a question thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for prot my
question um so it it's clear that uh
there are people that drive intoxicated
that have
um uh real issues with alcohol uh what
recourses do does the department have in
order to try to
rectify uh Behavior such
individuals thank you representative
bour I think the intellect program
the extension for violations can occur
there are certain types of behaviors
that can result in license suspension so
an example for a repeat offender that
can be utilized is if someone keeps
coming up to us for hearings because
they keep testing over the car doesn't
start we schedule them we look at the
history we can suspend the license for a
pattern of interlock failures in terms
of what a pattern is is that's really
not defined in the statute but to me
more than probably three is a pattern so
generally if I see 34 five prior
hearings for interlock extensions due to
test over or some other type of
violation I will also schedule it not
only for a violation to see if the
device should be extended but but for a
hearing to see if the license should be
suspended based on a pattern of failures
although kind of at the beginning of
this program one case that we saw we
kept seeing repeated failures for this
man and eventually his license was
suspended the interlock was removed
because he wasn't supposed to be driving
he got in a car without an interlock
device got charged with a DUI luckily he
didn't hurt anyone but he called our
office complaining about that we
suspended him the interlock got taken
out and he he was blaming us for his
getting a duy saying if you didn't
suspend my license I would have still
had an interlock I wouldn't have gotten
the
duy which I thought was was kind of an
interesting set of set of facts that
happened in that particular
case another
question uh yes um
so it seems like the only actions we can
have are uh uh increasing the uh uh use
of the internal o device
uh is there no way we can uh have this
issue of alcoholism addressed by the
individual rather than just uh extending
the the amount of time he his license
has
suspended I that's certainly a good
point representative bour because if you
don't address the underlying alcohol
issue although I think in terms of the
statutes the statutes would say the
requirement of completing the impaired
driver Care Management program before
license restoration addresses the the
alcohol issues although once someone has
completed that program and completed all
the Aftercare and then they get their
licenses back they're beyond mandatory
counseling although I think your point
is well taken is what can we do in the
law after someone leaves the idcm pro
idcmp program successfully in order to
address preventing future alcohol abuse
and I that's a good question I think
maybe it's one we continue to need to
work on to
much question thank you Mr chair my
question is very similar to the previous
one but uh I have a a few other things
that repres presid Gord did not uh ask
my question really it does center around
um cannot we at at some
point force a person to go through
treatment for their
addiction as part of the the program but
uh tied into that we have with the
opioid addiction seen a lot of um
driving well impaired that takes place
uh due to drugs that are not uh not
alcohol in major and I don't understand
how an interlock could work for somebody
who had habitually driven and been
charged with a DUI for heroin or another
substance and we do try to provide
support and treatment programs for those
who are addicted by other drugs but it
doesn't seem like we're doing the same
for those who are addicted to alcohol
and so I'm I'm asking where does the the
uh Department stand on on those issues
and what happens specifically with
interlock devices that wouldn't work
because the person's on a substance
other than
alcohol that's a question representative
Spain and that's what I hear from people
at some of these interlock hearings that
were not convicted of a DUI alcohol they
were convicted of a DUI drug and that's
what they will tell us they say it my
issue didn't involve alcohol so this
interlock is not helpful for me for for
my case I'm not sure if the intellect
technology can ever advance to address
the drug cases or not if there's
scientifically I just don't know what
the answer is to that whether breath
whether drug impairment can ever be
detected in breath or whether there's
some type of an equivalent device that
could detect drugs or
not so I think at this point that that
question is is not able able to be
answered adequately although I think
treatment would would be the answer for
those individuals rather than an
interlock device followup further
question follow up y thank you Mr chair
I have a followup in that
um my my question now is um based on on
the extent of the epidemic with the
opioid situation here in New Hampshire
and and we are one of the the hot spots
in the country and has been have you
seen data that shows that more of our
DUIs percentage wise are uh by those
people not abusing alcohol but abusing
other
substances and should we not start to
focus on addressing the broader scheme
of
things yes that's that's a point well
taken I'm not aware of what the
statistics are in terms of the breakdown
between DUI alcohol or DUI drug
convictions and I'm not sure what the
court statistics would be if someone's
convicted of DUI impairment if it splits
out in the complaint whether it's drugs
or alcohol I in the body of the
complaint it would but I'm just not sure
what statistics the court has on on that
distinction between drug conviction DUI
alcohola
yes thank you Mr chair for taking my
question uh thank you
uh uh so um I'm wondering uh how aware
are drivers of what the penalties for uh
uh DUI are at the moment and whether uh
so would someone know that at the moment
uh the um panel potential jail time for
prison time for a uh negligent homicide
in with the DUI was 6 to 12 and would
they be aware that it got increased to
10 to
20 yeah I'm not sure I think it would
depend on the individual although I
think there is a lot of public education
about the dangers of drunk driving and I
think the general public knows that if
you're driving drunk you you'll suffer a
penalty and you you should suffer a
severe penalty but it's hard to say if
they really know about the prison terms
and the extended term of imprison
prisonment as opposed to what's
currently available under
you I see other questions Mr chair
representative true oh represent true
I'm sorry thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr CCO for taking my question um uh
it's good to hear your voice again you
trans you uh you testifying
Transportation a lot the last couple of
here I know there's a division between
the penalty
DMV assesses I'm just trying to clear it
My Mind One More Time DMV is like a
civil case you you you could lose your
license from DMV or you could lose your
license at the same time being uh in a
criminal court for for negligent
homicide or other due to DWI there's two
separate
um punishments going on could be going
on at the same time is that correct it
could be DMV losing license and criminal
losing uh
Freedom yes that's correct and in the
negligent homicide case scenario
typically there would be a court
suspension for someone convicted of
negligent homicide and usually that same
case will go through an admin
administrative hearing for a license
suspension up to seven years for
involvement in a fatal motor vehicle
crash so those those are separate and
someone who is suspended through our
administrative process based on a fatal
motor vehicle crash has to have a second
hearing to be eligible to be restored so
they would serve the time it could be up
to seven years but it will be forever
until they come back for another hearing
and we review certain criteria make sure
certain things were satisfied even above
and beyond what the court may require if
alcohol was involved generally there
needs to be a ladak licensed alcohol and
drug abuse counselor evaluation is part
of our license reinstatement procedure
at the department of
safety thank you very much you're
welcome I see there are no other members
so representative clim you have ask
questions you may ask them thank you Mr
chair I did have another question that
just came up based on representative
tr's
question is the suspension of
license done concurrently or
consecutively to jail time because it
doesn't seem to me that suspending a
license with someone serving their jail
time is really very helpful and I would
hope that if they get a seven-year
sentence in jail for manslaughter that
the seven-year license suion takes place
after they get out
um and I'm just not aware of how that's
done that's a good question I think it's
up to the how the court imposes the
sentence it is a sentence I've seen that
would commence the license suspension
after release from
incarceration the same thing I think we
can word our hearing orders in the same
fashion and I know there was legislation
I remember a bill many years ago now
that I believe representative Smith
introduced to make that mandatory to to
have all the license suspensions
commence after release from
incarceration my memory of that bill
though is that it it did not pass and
was kind of left up to the sentencing
sentencing I see no other hands up thank
you very much for your testimony thank
it thank you for the opportunity I heard
you all speak about um a drug and
alcohol program um and whether that's
addressed and in our case Mr Leonard had
successfully completed two drug and
alcohol programs prior to killing my
son um in his sentence he did or the
judge did award six months off of his
prison sentence if he successfully
completed another drug and alcohol
program which we have since been
notified that he has completed and he
has been awarded six months off of the
sentence for completing that program for
a third
time and also as far as license
suspension in our cas case um his
license was suspended for 10 years and
during his six-year prison sentence
those six years will count towards his
10-year license suspension which is
another
failure of this process if he's
incarcerated and he cannot drive that
time should come after the fact of his
prison sentence being completed and
that's another huge failure when whether
it's the state the courts or
DMV but that I believe I believe needs
hands John is anyone else uh Mr chairman
I do not see anybody with their hands up
or tell then we will close the hearing
Mr chair we we do have uh Katherine
Cooper listed on the testimony list and
I do see her with her hand
raised yeah I didn't see that before
then it was not
there would you like me to allow that Mr
chairman yeah M
[Music]
Cooper um thank you representative Walsh
and members of the committee um this is
Katherine Cooper here on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers um we oppose both of
these V both of these bills um for
several reasons and I would like to
start by saying that I am so incredibly
sorry for the loss of um that young man
and I completely understand the
frustration and um just ongoing sadness
that that family is facing um because
there is no way to make these systems
perfect and um I know that's no
consolation but it is unfortunately the
reality um we do have issues with um HB
179 because this does create a major
escalation in the penalty for Fel um
aggravated driving and um I would note
that these are for um firsttime
offenses
there's also and I'm just being brief
here I did submit written testimony and
I would please ask you to refer to that
because there's a great more amount of
detail here and I'm trying to be quick
because I understand the time pressures
um but the language in this bill is
really confusing it looks like there is
a mandatory minimum trying to create be
created but then it says um the court
can
consider so if both of these amendments
are passed the maximum penalty for the
enhan offense will actually be less than
for the Baseline offense a 10 to 30 for
neg hom um or felony egg DUI with
serious bodly injury would be 10 to 30
but if you have one prior DWI it would
be 10 to 20 so there are some there are
some significant drafting problems here
for people who actually have to apply
the statute and use it on a day-to-day
basis um also with regard to I'll move
on to House Bill
347 um um the fir and this is for the uh
operating after suspension
charges so the first part of this bill
essentially elevates kind of a garden
variety violation level operating after
suspense or operate operating after
suspension um from a violation to a
misdemeanor and there were some
questions earlier about people
understanding penalties for the various
driving offenses and I can tell you in
no uncertain terms that 9 9% of people
who have sat in my office over the years
and the offices of my colleagues have
absolutely no clue the penalties um that
they are facing from the violations and
crimes that they have committed while
driving it it's it's a complex system
even when you work in and work in it day
in day out and the average citizen has
really no clue so there's a great deal
of there are huge problems with relying
on things as deterrents um in this area
of the
law um
also
the
[Music]
um there's a problem with this because
it's actually an unnecessary elevation
and if what we're really after is trying
to keep people who have convictions and
priors um in line and punish more
severely this already will happen
because if a person has an
administrative suspension and a
conviction for DUI they're already
subject to the 7-Day mandatory minimum
jail sentence for DWI suspensions so and
also if the OAS is based on reckless op
they already are subject to a class A
misdemeanor for operating under
suspension um finally just real quick
the second part of this bill extends the
7-Day mandatory minimum jail sentence
for operating after suspension um to out
of state DUI convictions and I just want
to point out that it might seem
Equitable to to have a prior conviction
from another state used as an
enhancement for this but you need to
understand and be ready to devote a lot
of money and a lot of time if you're
going to if you're going to make this a
crime and look for it to be enforced um
you have to get out of state records
certified the prosecutors and defense
attorneys are going to have to spend a
lot of time researching um outof state
laws and old case facts and of course
you know this is going to result in the
courts having to have more hearings and
trials because this is the kind of
charge that people will fight when
they're going to jail mandatory minimum
for seven days this is one of those
charges where judges don't even usually
want to give people a s-day jail
sentence so there's really no penalty
for going to trial you're you're likely
you're never going to beat the offer so
um we would request that both of these
bills be voted in expedient to
legislate thank
you co I have a question and and it's
related to something that you said said
how necessary is it for drivers to know
the consequences of their
driving I think anybody would know you
can't drive drunk you shouldn't what why
that
statement um I I I I agree with you
absolutely representative Welsh that
people know when they're sober that they
shouldn't drive drunk part of the
inherent problem with with drunk driving
offenses is that the reason we don't
want people driving being drunk is
because their judgment is impaired and
they make stupid decisions and one of
them is getting behind the wheel so it's
um it's a really tricky area of law when
you're trying to control people's
behavior and the people you're trying to
control are inherently being irrational
and exercising poor
judgment
so that that's one of the the really
difficult parts of this and it's you
know we have made a lot of progress in
this country on discouraging drunk
driving and and trying to create a
cultural shift with using Designated
Drivers and and making people think
about their drinking before they have
drinks and get behind the wheel um and I
I think in day-to-day life a lot of
progress has been made but there's
always going to be people that just
don't respond to those kind that kind of
social messaging and um you know
especially when there're people with
severe alcohol problems
PR I have a question uh it goes
basically to the same question Mr Welch
asked representative Welch um don't you
believe that after the first person is
sentenced to a STP or jail sentence for
killing somebody in a motor vehicle
accident that the wood would spread you
don't think that uh the public would
realize after the first person was
sentenc to jail for a longer sentence
that people would find out about that
that they would talk about it in the
bars talk about it in their
homes you don't think the would
sprad um with all due respect there's
actually studies that show that that
does not happen that the deterrence of
individual cases does not spread um and
in fact it's you know it's kind of
interesting a lot of times um my
practice over the years was based
primarily in the Sea Coast area of New
Hampshire and in Southern New Hampshire
and we would have people come in and
complain about how um weak the
sentencing laws are and when you
actually question people further it's
because they were watching Massachusetts
television they didn't even recognize
that the laws they were discussing were
not the laws of our state and were
repeatedly shocked to find out the New
Hampshire's laws were actually
significantly
harsher so um you know it's when you do
dedicated public education programs I do
believe that it makes a big difference
but I don't see a lot of impact from
Individual cases over the years um even
when they are reported in the paper and
not has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Cooper for taking the question
coming from a different perspective then
the law enforcement one which I sort of
brought up the same
question how
how many of the uh the problems that
that we're seeing with DUI these days
are attributable to alcohol and how many
to other substances and do you feel that
a lot of the problems could be and
should be addressed by confronting the
underlying problem of addiction through
mandatory treatment programs uh as part
sentencing um thank you for your
question representative Spain um I 100%
believe that our state should spend a
lot more money on substance abuse
treatment um in general and for driving
I I think there's a dir of of places for
people to go and get help um we do have
Federal funding available and we some in
some parts of the state they don't even
have places to send the money to um
because we don't have the structure set
up to give people the help that they
need on the ground I I think that's a I
problem I see no other hands
up much for your Tes oh hang on
representative
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question um what what is your opinion
about uh including in in the way the law
is being amended aggravated DWI in with
negligent homicide and and Ne and Murder
By DWI however that is do you think that
not um for I I'm sorry
what which section are you referring
to appreciate the
question yes we're we're it it
constantly refers to murder um negligent
um homicide
and I I think that including aggravated
DWI in with those two
crimes as I see it in the bill that
whether that's appropriate or not based
on the seriousness of the crimes and the
seriousness of
penalties um no we we would be opposed
to that um and the reason being those
are those are first offenses and what by
placing them there it also sort of
messes with the
entire um sentencing scheme by making
sentences for crimes that are
intentional versus negligent or you know
bad accidents unintentional um have
higher penalties than for example uh a
first-degree assault or a kidnapping I
mean this this bill what it does is it
would make the penalty for first offense
felony aggravated DUI
where the harm caused is
unintentional greater than for a first
degree assault or a kidnapping where the
person is actually intentionally harming
someone so I I think that's a that's a
major
problem thank you for that thank you for
that
answer see no further questions from the
committee thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much now
representative would you do the
honor
I will for uh for House Bill
179 there were two people who signed in
in support of the bill uh and six people
who signed in an
opposition and for uh House Bill
347 there were eight people who signed
in in support and there were two people
opposition that we will close the public
oh is that for both bills
yes yeah I'm sorry I wasn't paying
attention all right we'll close the
public hearing on out
179 and out
the
TR
are we on mute
still Representatives participating at
home hear
down
here time the executive session on House
Bill we now open the executive session
House Bill 347 all driving with supended
represent Mr chair I'd like to make pass
motion that motion has been seconded by
representative
Wallace
motion yeah representative board if you
are with us I recommend turning your
camera
on representative Ro you
recognized yes
chairman I actually have a lot of things
to say um I don't really know how to sum
it up quickly I just feel
that I just feel like if we have I feel
like personally there should prob be a
zero tolerance when it comes to driving
and I think we're on 3 347
now oh I'm sorry I'm on the wrong one
never
mind I was out of I
apologize
um I
feel first is SP this sh she's still
online you know heartfelt condolences to
her and I think whenever she spoke she
she was kind of speaking to both of
these bills and she just brought a lot
um I just think there should be zero
totally representative
G
um first of all enhance um
penalties I typically struggle with
because I really don't believe that it's
a deterrent never has been for any
situation but even more importantly um
you I don't think you were were you in
here when Katherine Cooper was talking
because she talked about how
confusing
um represent je I believe she was
confused by host 179 we're on this is
the executive
S7 347 uh I'm aware that this bill 347
passed in transportation last year I
believe unanimously and all it is is was
what was believed to be a housekeeping
matter where it was the only driving
offense that we could find where the out
ofate an out State Defense was not taken
into consideration
uh it did pass on Transportation
believe unfortunately was not Tak
consideration in the
Senate I'm not sure if it was table the
house the 19 pmic or t the
Senate all right can I just say that one
of the concerns that she had with the
out of state for 347 okay was the
expense not just for um let's say the
defendant but also for the state in
order to and and the lymph of a trial
and all those types of
things well I would say this when when
I represented someone who's charged with
you know offence and out of state
conditions
considered the the state has the burden
of proving the prior offense so it's the
state's job or burden to really get the
certified copy of the conviction I know
as a defense attorney why would I I
won't request it because I would just be
requesting incriminating evidence
against my client I feel ethically that
is not a good idea public record I will
leave it to the the government to to do
their job they're the ones that have to
prove the case if they fail to get that
information for whatever reason whether
it's by their own discretion or they
just failed to do it what would happen
is they're not going to prove the prior
offense and that it would simply just be
to be considered a first offense if it's
in state it's much easier to get that
information so I is an expense request
certified copies of the from
theard uh I I suppose it's the charges
by state but it's it's it's really not
that when I say expensive it's not
something that I would say is uh overly
certifi yes okay and the other thing is
that um not only let's say Massachusetts
their laws are different from New
Hampshire in most places they a little
bit different so that also meant as she
said that you had to learn the law of
that
land so I thought that was quite
interesting and my last question is
within the seven Why seven years
preceding the date of the
second I mean verse two years ver 10
years the seven years is already the
that's I don't know where that number
came from I
just problem with seven I just this was
just simply allowing you to take into
consideration a oy conviction for a
similar
offense again it's the the government's
burden to prove that it's a similar
offense if they can't prove that again
they're GNA have to make that
presentation otherwise I a problem heing
you're G have to I would you say provide
some type of
similar representative
Pratt that
same drivers Track Trail truck drivers
used to have a driver's license in every
state they used to have multiple
offenses go state to state have offenses
all over the country and they said that
they could never r that in today there's
one commercial driver license you truck
driver and any any ticket or any find
you get in any other state goes against
that license so I don't think it would
be that much of a problem to prove
person in another state they had two or
three strikes against them and then they
moved to New Hampshire to get away from
those two or three
strikes I don't think it be that hard to
prove where they came from they already
have strikes against them on drun
driving
charges or suspension
rication something that can't be done we
said that they could never do it
on
I think it's something that could
[Music]
be I can be
he represent PR do you mind repeating
what you said just saying a little
louder
yeah um so tractor trailer truck drivers
a number of years ago maybe 30 years ago
used to have multiple drivers license
across the country and they would get
tickets or fines or violations in the
state that they were in and then if they
lost that license it was okay they had
other licenses they had in other states
and they said at that time it would be
impossible in order to bring all these
states together to try to figure out if
a person has charges in another state
that has all beened now one driver's
license when you're a truck driver
anything you do in another state goes
against that license and I don't think
this is much different I think if you're
driving under a revocation or suspension
I don't think it' be a problem that um
you can find that out in another state
and maybe somebody would move from a
that they've had two or three violations
in to a state where they didn't have
violations if this isn't isn't corrected
they could move here from another state
where they have multiple violations and
then um it's not all over again it's not
the clock all over again so I think this
is something that could be can be done
reasonably you can find out from another
state if they have multiple strikes
against them and I think it's worthwhile
because you don't want to have somebody
start on the clock all over three times
in another state or another state
multiple times so so I think it's
something that's easily easily it's a
fix seeing no no hands raised uh the
matter when now be put the
question if you are in favor of motion
of to pass please say yay if you were
opposed please say May the cler can I
call the role Vice chairman Welch hi
representative
yes representative Spain yes
representative green
yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Marson y CLK
votes yes representative Harry G
no Representative
Representative
[Music]
no representative
HS
yourself
no representative golden
no representative Conley
yes representative Klein Knight
yes representative
Bradley
yes
chairman the chair votes yes Mr chairman
the vote the pass is 14 y seven
n by a vote of 14 Y and seven Nays the
motion ought to pass is
passed repres you preparing a majority
report yes will there be a Minority
Report I don't think
so
one if a member who voted in opposition
wishes to prepare my please let me know
by the end of the day
today at this time we will now close the
347 this time we opening the public
hearing on House Bill
632 standing a a sentence of Life of
imprison without
without
homicide you know that the sponsor is uh
a conflict is currently in judiciary
represent
the unless is he
him PA B
representative and
representative you just for
clarification are you going to introduce
just introduce the bill yeah defer
testimony questions if if do that you I
will the chair will allow access
discretion and permit you to still
question
Witnesses you testify and it it changes
that okay I'm just introducing it
not CH now recognizes representative Gap
to introduce House
Bill
632 good morning um I am representative
Linda har Gite out of Nashville Hills 36
w n and I'm here to open up six house go
632 for the prime
sponsor um just a little background on
um Bing a sentence of life in prison
without parole for juvenile convicted of
homicide decades ago in the tough on
crime 80s and 90s many states stoked by
fear of teen super Predators enacted law
to punish juvenile criminals like adults
the us became an international sent
sentencing offenders under 18 to live
out their lives in prison for homicide
and sometimes rape kidnapping or arm
robbery there has since been a
shift several years ago the US Supreme
Court banned mandatory life without
parole for juveniles in murder
cases then last year and I think this
would have been
2019 the court went further saying the
more than 2,000 already serving such
sentences must get an opportunity chance
to show their crime did not reflect
irreparable corruption and if not have
some Hope For
Freedom so we say that because in
Massachusetts for example there's
roughly
juveniles on life without parole
in 2015 Vermont eliminated life without
parole 14 17 and younger New Hampshire
the statistics that I was able to get
says that New Hampshire has five inmates
life without parole for crimes committed
at the age of
17 um there were a hearing scheduled for
two and the other two have not been
scheduled and I believe that one was
scheduled but refused to go to defend
himself in that hearing and Maine has no
joke juvenile
inmates so more importantly United
States is the only country that has life
without parole for juveniles and
medically speaking it's been documented
over and over
again that a juvenile typically their
reasoning and thought patterings do not
mature until in the mid
20s so
now I guess I could take questions if
someone wanted to but the prime spor
does plan on being here later
on and just just is the intent of the
chair to uh accomodate representative
B's uh schedule I know
he's yeah and I do know that there are
others that are
testifying as well I'm just saying that
in case I forget someone can remind
it happens okay representative
green thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you know what the
Ages were on the ones that killed that
woman in the Mount Vernon
case I'm just going to is this recently
uh about five years ago well then I
would say that's one of these 17y
olds I know the answer that
thank do you not know the
answer well um like I said the paperwork
that I found said that all of them were
17 that were in prison here in New
Hampshire so if uh representative
Spen um has some more updated
information I don't have a problem
representative Spen you may want to
address that thank you Mr chair um one
was 17 and the other was 19 thank you
thank you representative Welch ask for
question representative are you familiar
with a Pamela Smart Case and the three
juveniles who committed the crime yes
you know where they are now they're not
in prison she
is okay just thought i' bring that up
because not all
juveniles get life without parole and
those that
do
a long
time I'm to I believe that too they get
a long time but what we're saying is
that
um their lives matter as well and again
they're in a what I would say more a not
a mature state of mind and I would like
to believe that in this
society that someone has that has been
in prison for a while and um is worthy
of Rehabilitation and especially our
young
people and there was speaking of this
but I left it at home I just happened to
be online yesterday and there was
African-American male that had been in
prisoned for murder 86 years old was
released yesterday and he had been there
kid so obviously some somebody had
decided what he was 86 years old and I
guess well at this point he cannot do
any damage in life so let's just release
him but he was also one of those that
were
Coro seeing no further hands raised I
is representative Tony
[Music]
chairman they raise their hand if
they're there if any members of the
public wish to testify that have not
testified already uh please raise your
hand is there uh is there a
representative is there a someone here
to testify on behalf of the office of
the child
Advocates I see a hand of yes Mr
chairman would you like me to yes just
for the record just please identify
Yourself by by stating your full name
where you're from and whether you're
testifying in support or opposition to
House Bill
632 good morning this is Moira O'Neal
can you hear
me yes we can hear you great thank you
for the record my name is Moira O'Neal I
am the child advocate for the State of
New Hampshire um I appreciate the
opportunity U Mr chair to speak uh in
support of House Bill
632 um the office of the child advocate
is uh an independent oversight agency
recently our jurisdiction expanded to
Children's Services All Children's
Services that are provided or arranged
by the state however our Focus will
always be children who are involved
either in child protection or Juvenile
Justice so we put we support House Bill
632 um sentencing a child to life
without parole even for a crime of
homicide runs contrary to what we know
about the developing brain of children
the brain continues to grow and mature
through early adulthood reasoning and
critical thinking capacity evolves as
the brain grows and we know that
children are more susceptible to
influence given their developmental
capacity so we think about children as
learning from mistakes or listening to
what they're told and that sort of part
of growing up but actually a far it's a
far more complex process than that um we
now know from really elegant Imaging
studies and other research that the
frontal lobe of the brain including that
front prefrontal cortex is still
developing well into the mid 20s and the
structure and function of that part of
the brain determines a Young Person's
ability to think critically and to
reason um and to see even right from
wrong so the lack of development in that
area of the brain is often cited to
explain antisocial behavior um children
may not actually have the capacity to
anticipate their consequences of their
actions um so this extent of brain
development adolescence meaning from the
the ages of 10 to 24 can be influenced
by many factors that we're learning more
about all the time including
environmental stress risky Behavior drug
use sleep sex hormones nutrition and
other things their psychological status
and that means as these influences build
up in the developing brain a child's
brain at age 12 is very different than
at 16 and then more different at 18 um
and so on so most importantly the part
of the brain key to reasoning it insight
and cause and effect is the last part of
the brain to develop um so these
significant differences in children's
capacity given their developing brains
and the unique circumstances in which
many of them come into the Juvenile
Justice System including trauma
experiences should really be considered
in rendering sentences uh sentencing
decisions about their lives in the
crimin criminal justice system children
who commit the crime of homicide are
often severely abused and neglected and
have experienced a tumultuous home home
life similarities have been found among
children who commit murder including
having unreliable and ineffective
caregivers family members with criminal
records witnessing or experiencing
violence traumatic loss and being
rejected or abandoned by a parent but
the science tells us is the cause for
children's Behavior it also predicts
children's brains that will grow past
that behavior um if they're able to
engage and be provided with Supportive
Services so it's not entirely hopeless
um children will become better um
citizens so over the past 20 years and
what we've learned in science about the
developing brain has influenced a series
of decisions by the United States
Supreme Court regarding juvenile
sentencing and proportional punishment
in 2005 the United States Supreme Court
decided in Roper V Simmons in which it
ruled that the eth and the 14th
amendments of the Constitution ban
imposition of the death penalty on
offenders who were under 18 at the time
the crime was committed the crime found
I'm sorry the court found that three
differences between juveniles and adults
demonstrating that juvenile offenders
can't be reliable um to be classified
among the worst offenders first as any
parent knows and as the scientific
sociological studies um tend to confirm
a lack of maturity and an underdeveloped
sense of responsibility are found in
more often than in adults and are more
understandable among the young these
qualities often result in impetuous and
Ill considered actions and decisions
second as I mentioned earlier juveniles
are more vulnerable or susceptible to
negative influences and outside
pressures including peer pressure and
third the Supreme Court stated that the
character of a juvenile is not as well
formed as that of an adult so
personality traits of juveniles are more
transitory un less fixed that's all
coming from the court um and then later
in Graham versus Florida um decided in
2010 the Supreme Court ruled that the
eth Amendment to the United States
Constitution does not permit a sentence
of life without parole for juveniles
convicted of a crime other than homicide
in that case the court found that life
without parole is an especially harsh
punishment for a juvenile under this
sentence a juvenile offender will on
average served more years and a great
percentage of his time in prison than an
adult offender and it further noted that
deterrence does not suffice to justify
the sentence and they cited Roper the
court stated that the same
characteristics that render juveniles
less capable and adults suggest that
juveniles will be less susceptible to
deterrence again in another case in
2012 Miller versus Alabama drawing from
its decisions in roer and Graham the
court decided that the eighth of
Amendment forbids imposition of a
mandatory life without parole sentence
for juvenile offenders convicted of
homicide the court explained that
children are con constitutionally
different from adults for purposes of
sentencing so it found that Graham's
flatband on life without without parole
for non-homicide crimes noting that
Graham said about children is crime
specific those features are evident in
the same way and to the same degree if a
botched robbery turns into a Kill
so Graham's reasoning implicates any
life without parole sentence imposed on
a juvenile even as its categorical bar
relates only to non homicide offenses so
most fundamentally Graham insists that
youth matters in determining the
appropriateness of a lifetime
incarceration without the possibility of
Parole in 2014 the New Hampshire Supreme
Court ruled in Petition of the State of
New Hampshire that Miller decision
applied retroactively to four New
Hampshire respondents who had been
convicted as juveniles of life without
parole for homicide and while Miller
while the Miller Court considered
mandatory sentence of life without
parole its reasoning applies equally to
any sentence of life without parole for
juveniles so Banning life without peal
sentences for juveniles who commit
homicide will codify the principles
espoused in those cases regarding
sentencing of juveniles will also bring
New Hampshire into alignment with other
states there are 24 States and the
District of Colombia that have banned
life sentences without the possibility
of parole for juveniles four states have
parole we do have to limit testimony we
have been limiting two to three minutes
for hearing okay sure sure so I'm happy
to take questions if you have any we're
at seven minutes so we do need to uh I
do need to ask you to suspend the
chair's a mistake for it not clarifying
that before you any teson sure
understood if you have questions I'll
answer them otherwise thank you for
taking my Tes question uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um in your testimony you spoke
of uh the brain development from 10 to
24 years old now in the 2010 Kimberly
Gates case one individual that was
charged with first-degree murder was 17
the other one first-degree murder was um
19 you know this bill if I understand it
right is just anybody under 18 um so why
not the 19y old if what you're saying is
the uh you know the 10 to 24 year old
you know brain isn't mature enough sure
thank thank you very much for that
question and and if we if we followed
the science then we would extend out the
the age limit I think um what you're
considering is what is politically
expedient um but certainly the
scientists and the advocates for
children would argue for um for an older
age and I will tell you from experience
because we meet with children at the
cunu Youth Services Center often um that
I've actually um had the opportunity to
meet and and um and know children who
are moving on not necessarily for life
without parole but for for children who
come into the system early say around
age 14 and then leave at 18 for an
adults system um it's a completely
different individual um there's a
there's a child at age 14 who has done
something um that was wrong and
certainly acknowledges it but at 18 it's
a it's a it's a young adult who has
completed schooling is taken college
courses is helping out with other
students um a completely different and
responsible person whose life um that he
has to look forward to um is behind
prison
I want to thank you for your testimony
and the chair would would uh inquire
like to ask a question I want to thank
you in advance for taking my question uh
in your testimony you stated that the
development of the human brain does not
complete is not completed
to an average adult reaches the age of
the mid 20s if that is if that is the
case why would this be this law what's
the rest of having this simply be at the
age of you know the juvenile age
wouldn't it be the age of mid
20 thank you for that question Mr chair
and and it's somewhat of a a repeat of
the other question in in in terms of the
age limits um as I said the science
would support extending out um a piece
of legislation like this to older youth
up to age 24 um but as as as we all have
to consider in public policy what's
expedient for the community what the
community is comfortable with I would
stand by um advocating for it to include
older youth um but understand that that
pass thank you for take my question to
representative CL
night thank you chairman and thank you
for taking my question um so if I'm
understanding what you're saying is that
um the age that's written in this bill
now is okay because we have to start
somewhere is that correct thank you for
the question yes it is it would be it
would be a far better Bill if it um if
it extended the age up to
24 thank
[Music]
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the WT for for the testimony thank
you very much for hearing
me
just for the members of the public who
wish to testify that are in attendance
pleas at this time please raise your
hand the chair will be limiting
testimony two minutes per witness I do
apologize that I did not state that for
the prior witness uh beginner testimony
so
I apologize uh chair now recognizes uh
Eric
Alexander
Eric yes can you all hear me yes thank
you chairman Vice chair and uh committee
having me with you today um I am Eric
Alexander and I serve as senior advocate
for the campaign for the fair sing of
Youth where we work to replace like with
our parole and Other Extreme penalties
for children with age appropriate
responses to their actions as mentioned
earlier the US Supreme Court has made
several rulings on this issue and has
concluded that it should be reserved and
applied only in cases where the
individual is determined to be
encourageable went on to add that youth
should be awful a reasonable opportunity
for release since then the majority of
the country has moved away from life
without parole as a citizen option for
children and over 700 youth who were
told that they would die in prison are
now home over 140 of those youth um you
know who are men and women are active
members of a network which I help to
co-found which is I can um and you know
that's an acronym for the incarcerated
Children's Advocacy Network um all of
them serve time for for hmde related
offenses and are now home living
productive lives as uh you know some as
Elementary School teachers some as
substance abuse counselors paral leals
entrepreneurs um um Etc contributing to
the communities in a variety of positive
ways with the understanding that you
know they could never repay what they
took um you know they cons decided to
find their time in prison uh finding
ways to repay Society for the mistakes
that they made um you know these youth
are not monsters you know I can testify
to that because I was once one of those
children um at the age of 17 I was part
of a crime that cost a man his life and
two I was on a case with a 19y old um
and you know also a 16y old
the only way that I avoided life without
the possibility of herole was that I
play guilty to two 25 year sentences I
served 10 years at that time and I'm
home now um I've been home now for 17
years since that time um I've been
employed by organizations like the YMCA
the Metro Public School System here in
Nashville Tennessee um and and now I'm
um you know entering my fourth year in
my tenure with the campaign for the fair
sentencing of Youth so I said all you
know all of that to say that these are
the type of things that these youth are
capable of when they come home at a
reasonable time um again I went to
prison at the age of 17 and I came home
at 28 you know since then um you know
I'm a married man um I have two
beautiful daughters the age of of five
and three so I've been able to put my
life back together in a very meaningful
way and I truly believe that this is
what the Supreme Court said when they
meant that these children should have a
meaningful opportunity for release now
as someone who spent time in prison I'll
tell you that not all youth will meet
the parole board standard but you know
they should have an opportunity to sit
in front of parole board and have the
parole board to U have an opinion on if
they are a citizen that's that's um
available for release or if they are
someone who needs to spend more time in
prison getting their lives together uh
testimony seeing No Hands
raised the witness is
excused at this time uh the chair I
recognize representative Paul
bur uh I did state that testimony will
be limited to two minutes per witness
however representative bur was the Prime
sponsor was unavailable at the start of
the hearing so there will be some
flexibility with that respect for the
represent thank you Mr chair I
appreciate the courtesies I've received
from you in the committee I was tied up
in judiciary doing execs until a few
moments ago um I am the prime sponsor of
HB 632 my name is Paul Birch I represent
chesher 1 which are the towns of West
Milan Walpole Chesterfield and Hinsdale
along the banks of the beautiful
Connecticut River um I assume by now you
have heard from uh various experts and
and other folks who have an interest in
this bill uh I wasn't able to hear them
because I was tied up but I will keep my
marks quite short so as not to repeat
what they likely said
um I filed this bill in part because
actually I got a pretty thoughtful
letter from an inmate at the conquered
State Prison who would not be subject to
this bill but felt that this would be an
important bill judging from uh what he
has learned and what he has seen um as a
former public defender and as a
legislator I get a lot of such mail this
one kind of struck me uh in a certain
way so I I decided to file the bill uh
as has been noted this bill does not
guarantee the release of any offender
just a review after a reasonable period
of incarceration with an individualized
assessment of course of unique
circumstances of each in offender and I
want to make a point I don't know if it
was made earlier but it also allows the
victim's
family and friends to possibly evolve
their own thinking
about what a just and a compassionate
sentence might be at uh a point in time
maybe a year after the uh the loss of a
loved one from a violent crime they may
have one point of view and 30 years
later they may or may not have a
different point of view and I think it's
respectful of those folks to say yes we
want to hear your changed point of view
if you have it or you're not non-change
point of view and take that into account
in figuring out the continued sentence
or not as you have heard Most states
have either eliminated this Statute in
law or in
practice uh and this is based on what we
know of Child
Development uh our knowledge of Child
Development has changed a lot over the
last few decades uh and that's been
reflected in Court decisions which I'm
sure have been mentioned to you uh in
the earlier testimony you know
immaturity of children Su
susceptibility to outside pressures and
influences inability to assess
consequences all suggest that punishment
for adults should be considered
different than punishment for children
there's a cost factor of course it's
expensive to jail folks the national
average is about 35,000 a year it goes
up
tremendously for for geriatric prisoners
it's an issue that's larger than this
bill uh but it's an issue that uh uh
affects all of us who work in our County
uh budget committees and uh on our state
budgets but the costs of care for
geriatric prisoners is double that of
younger prisoners so um it's an issue as
taxpayers would like has to look at uh
there's an issue of Rehabilitation and
rehabilitative programs if you have a
child who's locked up for life there's
little incentive to give him or her any
kind of meaningful Rehabilitation under
the theory that they're not going to
ever be released um that's not good
penology it's not good uh it it's not
good corrections to have that approach
but it's there I hate to say it but
there's racial
disparities in a lot of the criminal
justice issues and this one is no
exception uh the imposition of life in
prison without parole for children is
has been found to be racially uh
disperate um similar in capital
punishment and and other kinds of
similar issues so briefly that's uh
where I'm at filing this bill it's a
nonpartisan bill it's not uh left or
right I it's uh it's a good government
bill um and basically sentences that
sentence juveniles to jail for the rest
of their lives without the best
possibility of parole close the door on
Rehabilitation and Second Chances deny
the family and friends of the victim the
chance to revisit rethink their position
about what an appropriate sentence is
and it's basically cruel and misguided
so I hope you will support uh passing HB
you representative first I want first
thank you for your testimony the chair
May inquire H
question are you familiar with the the
PRI Witness reference the Miller ver
Alabama
case and I believe that my understanding
of the holding in that case and please
just correct me if I'm wrong uh for a
juvenile the Supreme Court ruled that
they can't be a mandatory sentence of
life without parole for a juvenile
however a juvenile could still be
sentenced to life without parole but
it's just the law can't mandate that is
that would you agree that that is the
holding in the M Alabama case that is
correct and then my my thank you for
taking my question my followup question
is in the state of New
Hamshire with the exception of
first-degree murder are there any
other offenses that you are aware of
where the mandatory sentence would be
for a
juvenile where they would be sent that
that juvenile would be
sentenced life
Al no I'm not aware of
any thank to this would really just
apply to first degree murder we're aware
of I believe so I mean I have to check
on SEC with the penalty on second
deegree murder is because I think maybe
in New Hampshire it's the same penalty
for first and second but I'm not
positive of that I think
and someone I just up I was looking at
that right before I asked the question
the uh RSA 630 would apply I believe
First to be murder it's
life uple but second degree you can he
sent this to a have a life sentence but
it's not
necessarily
um the automatic
Deni I'm only wear first agre I'm just
wonder if there's any other offenses
right but under uh you under the Miller
case the the mandatory life without uh
uh parole for juveniles is not allowed
anymore yeah so I guess the feeling is
that
So based on the testimony and the your
understanding of the Miller vers Alabama
case RSA
6301 if a juvenile was convicted of
first degree
murder that sentence has applied in that
particular circumstance would violate
that Supreme Court
holding if they were given the Mandate
given as a mandatory yes I
agree thank you representative none of
appreciate representative
Muse yes thank you for taking my
question um just wanted a little
clarification on the build of the way
it's the way that it's actually written
um is it possible under your bill for a
juvenile to still receive a life
sentence for a crime but with the
stipulation that uh that they would be
Point under this bill a juvenile could
still be sentenced to life
imprisonment there's no guarantee of any
parole all this does is say that at some
point in time the juvenile is entitled
to a hearing before a parole board which
can say yes or can say no in other words
if the parole board thinks each time or
whenever they see this person that this
person should remain in jail and that's
the decision that is made for the rest
of that person's natural life that's
what will
happen thank you that was my assumption
again represent the chair May inquire
follow question I'll this is just my
reading of what would If This Were to
pass and signed the law it would a new
section RSA
6307 would appeal I'm reading that to
say that no juvenile convicted as an
adult for an
offense can be sentenced to life prison
so although that would satisfy the the
Miller versus Alabama
holding I'm reading this to not allow
any circumstance where a is sentenced to
life is on the second Dee murder it's
some discretionary facts May considered
by the judge to actually you know issue
a life sentence but it's just not a
mandatory sent I guess my question is
I'm reading that differ we
testify
misunderstood I'm not sure I follow
um I try to make it as clear me and Os
can make it that I mean the Supreme the
Supreme Court has ruled out for for this
category of offender uh life in prison
with uh mandatory life in prison without
parole that's off the
table this takes it that sentence of
life in prison without parole for a
juvenile convicted of of this offense
off the table and means there has to be
some ability to face a parole board does
not guarantee parole it just says you
have a right to ask for parole or or
ship on testifying uh please that are in
attendance please raise your hand at
this time uh president sh you may begin
your testimony and please uh try to
testimony under two minutes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you to the other
members of the committee and um to to
representative Burch for introducing
this legislation I'm Preston ship I
serve as senior councel uh senior policy
councel for the campaign for the fair
sentencing of Youth you've already heard
from my esteemed colleague Eric
Alexander uh and so I Will Not Duplicate
his testimony the thing that I would
like to share with you um because you're
getting it right you you've heard about
the US Supreme court cases uh the
campaign has been working on this issue
since 2009 and so we have uh been active
in States all over the country you've
heard that 25 States uh so far U
including DC 25 have already passed this
kind of legislation so the only thing
that I really wanted to add uh was just
to let you know that if you pass House
Bill
636 I'm sorry
632 you're basically bringing yourself
in line
not just with your neighbor of of
Vermont um and Massachusetts but also
West Virginia and Virginia and
Ohio um Utah and Wyoming and
Nevada uh and believe it or not Arkansas
and Texas Texas was one of the first
states to abolish life without the
possibility of parole for kids after the
Miller decision in 2012 the very next
year Texas passed a law saying that no
child could be sentenced to life without
parole in their state they basically
said that you know if a kid is too young
to vote too young to sign a contract too
young to serve on a jury or in the
military then that person is too young
to be uh condemned to die in prison and
so New Hampshire would certainly be in
good company both conservative and
Progressive States the bill we we just
saw passed in Ohio Republicans have
super majorities in both Chambers in
Ohio uh and they took this issue up and
and really show that this this is a
conservative issue not just a
progressive issue and so we're really
really happy for this opportunity that
new New Hampshire has certainly we want
to be a resource for you if if there's
any questions or materials that we can
provide we would just love to do that
and again we thank you for your
consideration
[Music]
today thank you for your
testimony uh see seeing No Hands raised
I want to thank you for your testimony
and you are
excused is representative
Tony
Mesa if any members of the public who
are present and wish to testify uh at
this time please raise your
hand thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Jeanie hesa
I'm the political director for the ACLU
of New Hampshire and I appreciate the
opportunity to appear before you again
today uh in support of HB 632 and ending
the inhumane practice of sentencing
children to life in prison without the
possibility of parole I want to respond
to some of the questions that have been
asked about whether to extend this to
19y olds and I and I appreciate the
question and I want to know is as a
society we have put significance on the
age of 18 this bill does not F does not
come up with that distinction between 18
and afterwards minors are not considered
responsible enough to live away from
their parents to make decisions related
to their education or medical treatment
to vote to sign a contract and yet they
can be certified as a so-called adult
and sentenced to spend the rest of their
lives behind bars
what a what an lwop sentence means is
that someone is
irredeemable I don't know how we say
that about a minor who is still
developing including cognitively you're
saying that a minor a minor somebody as
young as 13 14 15 is
irredeemable even if given decades to
rehabilitate I just don't know how we
say that um and I and I think it's
really worth noting that the United
States is the only country in the world
that sentences people under the age of
18 to life sentences without the
possibility of parole and as previous
Witnesses have noted the trend within
the United States is to do away with
these sentences 24 States plus DC have
already done so um so it's a great
opportunity here for New Hampshire to
catch up um and I just want to note
again this bill does not prevent young
people from being held accountable that
is not the question if you commit a
heinous crime you should be held
accountable this bill simply ensures
that a minor is not condemned for life
for something they did when the world
over recognizes them as immature and not
fully cognitively developed juveniles
who commit heinous crimes would still
face accountability they would still
face stiff sentences and would still go
before the parole board and have to
prove that they have been rehabilitated
and Worthy of parole so and I and I do
want to know as as there have been a
couple individual cases referenced in
New Hampshire and there and they're
currently a couple cases pending like
this is a very relevant issue here and
now um and this is a value question this
is a value of what of how our state
treats children um so I strongly
encourage this committee to really
consider HB 632 I will know I understand
there's some confusion about the wording
um given the lwop termin ology um so
maybe maybe the wording could be
clarified so that the questions that the
committee raised about the specific
phrasing of the bill um don't continue
and it's very clear what the bill is
striving to do um but I very very much
support the intent of the bill um and
urge this committee uh to pass this
much thank you for your testimony uh
representative bro you recognize for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for my question and I I guess maybe
I should have asked a previous speaker
but maybe you know the answered how many
are currently serving a life sentence
that were sentenced under 18 in New
Hampshire and how many um in the past
have been sentenced that and they may
not be with us
today I don't know that off the top of
my head I think the number 17 was
mentioned earlier today by but that's
just me quoting a previous witness I
don't know that off the top of my head
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for a testimony thank
you the chairel recognizes Helen Hanks
something good afternoon honorable
members of the committee my name is
Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner of the
New Hampshire Department of Corrections
I've just been an active uh listener to
your testimony today in response to
representative Burton to representative
Harry garthright just I just sent you a
data set to help you answer those
questions um and certainly uh we we stay
neutral as you vet this question but are
Avail ourselves to provide you any
information that assists you in vetting
this proposed piece of legislation so I
just want to point you to your emails
there's some information there in
addition to I did send you the health
care cost by age group I did see a typo
and my state fiscal year 2020 I just
want to assure you it is State fiscal
year 2020 you'll see a reference to
2018 and we're again here to help triage
any information you might need thank
you thank you Miss H for your testimony
represent you recogn ask for question uh
thank you Mr chairman and U thank you
for jumping in here uh and sending us
that information that I'll definitely
look at but it I don't know if in the
information States what my question was
is that you know how many are currently
serving life sentence that were
sentenced under 18 years of age
currently in New Hampshire and then
let's say back you know the 200 years
you know 250 years we've been here how
many have done that uh representative
Bert it's actually a pretty detailed
data set you'll find it gives you the
age they were at the date of offense it
gives you the crime it gives you the
date of their crime you'll see a
reference to minimum and maximum the
numbers 9 9 denote a life sentence Did
also give you additional data for people
who were serving 50 years or more that's
pretty significant um and it has a
you're going to see a lot of detail
there are public data sets um so we just
wanted to get that to you I do not could
not commit to um some long-term data as
we switched systems back in 2008 but
I'll try to see what I can find for
historical perspective with regard to
the state of New
welcome seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for her testimony and
excused if there any members of the
public and attendance that wish to
testify that have not testified already
hand seeing seeing No Hands raised at
this time we will close the public
632 representative M do you may want to
honors yes people signing in on host
Bill 632 there were 152 people who
signed in in support uh there were five
opposition I'm just we're gonna
go a recess very shortly but just
something for everyone to think about uh
what what I've least been reviewing
during the hearing and what we heard
from testimony the M Alabama
case pretty clear you can't have a
mandatory life sentence without the
eligibility eligibility of appr for a
juvenile answer the first-degree murder
law
RSA it's RSA
630 one-
a states that that offense is is a
mandatory of Life above the whole
so that as written applied to a juvenile
would not pass the Supreme Court must
that's the holding of Miller versus
Alabama uh but something to think about
is whether we would want to forbid a
life sentence without the possibility a
judge can still make our or issue a life
sentence it's just a matter
of it being mandatory that's doesn't
prevent a judge from doing that as part
of the sentence it's
just it's confusing but just something
to think about do we want to make it so
it's impossible to under any
circumstance for a juvenile to serve a
life sentence
without so we I think we least need to
consider whether we want we have to
eliminate the Mandate of that because
that's the Law's pretty clear on so this
something to consider about we'll be uh
we'll be doing some executive sessions
uh this plan to be uh be back back at 1
recess
sh
what
by
just for the members in the room if
you're speakers are also un unmuted that
learning
be5
just
had
right good afternoon everyone can the
members at home uh hear us if they can
fromes
Bradley we are going to be opening a few
on
[Music]
represent does it look like she's with
us
recommend someone
out text
time look for a copy of the actual
[Music]
somewhere good afternoon everyone at
this
time we open the executive session House
Bill
179 relative to enhanced penalty bed on
prior for driving under the influence of
drugs or
liquor at this time the chair is will
recognize representative rhs to make a
motion about the pass I we offer an
amendment thank you Mr chairman I do
have an amendment um for house
179 to pass the amendment the amendment
is21
0741 and is there a second to that
motion to pass that's seconded by
representative
green I second the motion thank you and
you you wish offer amend yes um
was
well
David could you grab me one please does
amendment one that named it Tyra right
yes and to my understanding the only
correction uh only part of the the bill
that's being amended would be to add
that that
title so it doesn't change the substance
[Music]
underlying
okay
anyone wish to discuss the
amendment
seeing seeing No Hands raised the matter
will now be put the question on the
question is whether to adopt um
Amendment
d07
41h if you're in favor of adopting the
amendment please say yay
opposed please say nay the clerk will
now call the
RO Vice chairman Welch
I representative
Spain I out
sorry okay representative bir yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testman yes
representative true y representative
Pratt yes representative Maron
yay per VES yes representative har G
yes representative Vixie
yes representative of Hearn yes
representative
B
no representative
Muse yes
representative
Newman
yes representative Balden yes
representative Conley yes representative
K Knight yes representative Bradley yes
chairman the chair votes
represent I did call his name first and
the vote is 20 y
one by a vote of 20 Y in one day the
adopted represent Ro you wish to make a
motion about the pass as as amended yes
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion uh for house9 L to
pass as amended as amended that second
it
seconded by representative
Wallace you wish to speak to the motion
yes I first like to say I um I apologize
I had my notes written on this
particular bill and I was talking on the
other Bill prior um both having to do
with driving out of the inflence I
apologize for that confusion but we had
a lot of testimony today
um one of the things that is really
ringing the bell to me is um there was
testimon that well when a person is
driving out of influence they're not
able to make the best decisions and
therefore they shouldn't be held
responsible which is a little bit har me
and understand um and also listen to
miss Shaw's testimony as I was saying
before and her you know really bringing
to light just using the exact words what
they are the son was killed and it
wasn't by a person that was making a
mistake it's a person who made clear
conscious
decision to drive while they were drunk
repeatedly
and you know schools have a zero
tolerance for bullying but yet we don't
have a zero tolerance for things like
this where you know words can be more
harmful than someone drive and drunk is
really hard to understand so with that
being said
discussion
representa Muse you
recognized yes one of the things we've
heard you know over the course of uh you
know of this year in criminal justice is
that sometimes the the worst case
scenario cases don't necessarily
translate into the best state
law
um I I have no doubt that uh that what
happened to to Misha and her family is
is terrible um but I do have doubts as
to whether or not this bill is actually
going to move us any farther towards
fixing this problem um I think one of
the things that we heard in the
testimony uh were a lot of people who
were um uh extremely well-intentioned um
who were also trying to explain to us so
some other holes that you know that we
needed to fix um there were things
regarding the the instrumentation that
takes uh or that uh uh that offenders
have to breathe into uh in order to
start their cars
um we're looking
at an extremely significant increase in
the penalty uh for this uh and and I and
I think the and I think one of the
things that uh Miss Cooper pointed out
to us is that we would actually be
making a crime that um I'm not sure
anyone would intentionally ever commit
um into an offense with a greater
punishment into you know then a lot of
offenses on our books that people commit
with full
intent so um I'm regretfully I have to
say that uh as the bill currently stands
it
recognized thank you Mr chair
and I agree with representative Muse and
my primary objection to the bill is that
there are many ways that you can uh
commit aggravated uh DWI and the
inclusion of aggregate aggravated
DWI Al into the uh laws that cover uh
manslaughter and and murder DWI I think
is just not appropriate so I'm going to
you representative green thank you Mr
chair being in Criminal Justice and
public safety for four terms and seeing
a lot of bills come through where
they're trying to protect the guilty and
not the
victim and uh I just uh feel bad the
victims aren't looked at so much in this
state or maybe not this state but just
across the
this
you recognize go back several terms ago
we had another DWI bill which had a
mandatory
uh jail sentence for the first time
offender and the reason I got involved
in that one was because my niece who
lives in Washington
state was driving with a fiance on the
car and they got hit head on by a
guy and it was he this is the first time
I've ever driven
drunk well statistics show that people
who get caught DWI have probably driven
2,000 times without getting
this way her is with us she went through
the
windshield
seeing no further hands
raised the matter will now be put to
question if you support of the motion
the pass as
amended please say yay if you oppose
please say nay the clerk will now call
the rooll vice chairman Welch yes indeed
representative Burke yes representative
Spain yes representative green very much
yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true y representative
Pratt yes representative Marson yay
clerk votes yes representative Harry
gathre
no representative Bixby
no Representative o'n
no Representative bour
no representative muse no
representative
Newman
no representative Conley
yes representative Klein
KN
yes representative Bradley
yes chairman the chair votes
yes Mr chair the vote is 14 yay 7
n by a vote vote of 14 Y and seven a the
motion of a to pass has amended has
passed I uh he I do know that um sen
couldn't make it today but I will give
him credit for drafting the original
version which was Senate Bill
this time we
now be comparing preparing the majority
report yes will there be a Minority
Report
yes at this time we now close the
this time we are opening executive
196 have a copy of the bill want to read
appreciated Mr chairman is an act adding
trespass as an
threat exemption I'm sorry exemption let
me ReRe
it that's from last week yes and there
was there was an amendment I understand
do the members at
[Music]
amendment this time recognize
representative
B make a motion thank you Mr chairman
I'd like to make a motion of off to pass
amendment yes can you please read the is
that when you say off the pass with an
amendment are you referring to you make
a motion of pass offer an amendment is
that amend mment number
202-
0758 yes it is Mr chairman than you who
is that second second by representative
Ro representative
B you wish to speak to the amendment yes
Mr chairman um what the amendment does
it basically removes the
$1,500 amount out
of the current bill that is being
proposed and the reason um
um you know it's hard to determine what
values are on some items
and when it comes to certain
items you know the value may be less but
to the person it's
everything um so by allowing not to have
any amount I think just makes the bill
more enhanced
Mr thank you representative
[Music]
discussion seeing No Hands raised the
matter will now be put the question if
you are in support of adopting Amendment
07588 please say yay if you're opposed
nay Vice chairman wch hi representative
B yes representative stain yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
PR yes
representative Marson
yay clerk votes yes representative
Harriet Gaff
no representative Bixby
no Representative o'n
no representative
Bourne
yes representative M
no representative Newman
no representative bden
no representative Conley no
representative Klein Knight no
representative Bradley no chairman the
chair votes yes Mr chair the vote is 12
y n nay I voted 12 Y and nine Nays
Amendment 20 21-
0758 is
adopted you now we make a motion of a to
pass as amended yes Mr chairman I would
like to make a motion of to pass as
196 you wish to second that motion
yes representative Burke do you wish to
speak to the motion of to pass as
amended uh yes Mr chairman U thank you
and very briefly uh you know this bill
just allows people
to be able to defend
their property uh without being
criminally charged and certainly on this
incident
of defensive
display and hopefully we'll all vote for
chairman the matter will now be open for
discussion representative Conley thank
chairman deal with bills of this kind of
session um RS
74 physical force in defense of a person
essentially our self-defense statute is
very clear is also uh already addresses
this situation and basically any other
where somebody has a
reasonable concern about their own
safety or about their property this this
bill and others like this term have
created I see is car vs who statue that
already intend to address situations
much like this one without
specifying uh where it would occur um I
don't think this bill is needed RSA 6274
clearly uh addresses this exact same
scenario considered in the bill the bill
makes it less clear the current statute
uh perfectly addresses this we don't
bill
representative
Muse you one of my biggest concerns with
this bill and some others that we've had
in this session um that are similar is
that uh to a large extent uh these bills
are motivated by fears of protests uh uh
in other states that simply haven't
happened in New Hampshire um I have a
problem
sorry this it's we as to the quum we not
allowed to speak to other members
motivate uh motivations for filing the
bill so I just ask if you refrain
from that I however you make you may
continue I thank
you thank you I I I I have a general
problem with people uh trying to settle
arguments or disputes with a with a gun
um that's what words are for um and
another thing that I worry about in a
state that has a first in the nation
primary and then one where um where
politics seems to be our state sport
instead of uh football uh basketball
baseball or hockey uh is I worry about
the impact on
canvassers um I've actually uh
experienced an incident myself where uh
where I was uh going up to knock doors
back in the in the 2016 election uh and
I was looking to uh to talk with the uh
with the woman of the house uh and the
man of the house was outside raking
leaves and asked me who I was canvasing
for and when I told him uh he pointed at
a pistol on at his side so you know
these are these are the sort of things
that we open the door to with this bill
and I think it's one of the reasons why
we really really need to think twice U
you
representative
gab I just want to remind us that when
um and the sign of sheet there was 12 to
support and 53 in opposition to this
bill and I think that sometimes we
really need to take a look at that as
why people are opposing bills and or why
they're actually supporting a
information
representative Wallace thank you Mr
chairman um thank thanks for letting me
speak this bill would provide legal
protection to a property owner who is
taking an offensive posture with a
firearm or another means of
self-defense to neutralize or deescalate
threat in a criminal threatening
situation this doesn't have anything to
do with canvasing or being at the mall
or anything like that it's
specifically to help you deescalate a
situation on your own property or cour
that representative true thank you Mr
chair um I do support uh this uh this
amendment I believe it is it is very
possible for uh somebody who
is to be found innocent of uh
of such an action to be financially
ruined just by defending himself in
court this CER this restates and
clarifies the situation where a person
is certainly within his legal rights to
uh protect himself in his
chair just expand on that by expanding
on when a person can defend thems and
specifically display a firearm in
defensive matter it
also specifies and implies when it's not
appropriate I believe the example
provided by representative news just
based on what he said to us that would
sound very inappropriate display of a
fire because it doesn't sound and
knowing represented me very well it
doesn't sound to me like there was any
reason we know what a reasonable person
believe that represent whatever caused
property damage seriously B injury or
death to anyone so that I would say that
this clarifies when it's
appropriate and unfortunately sometimes
when laws are more broad it makes it
very difficult to prosecute this this
really Narrows when it is appropriate so
this could be interpreted really as a
narrowing of when it's appropriate by
so
ause
something that I think we need to
consider is um the fact that yes people
can interpret the law differently but I
think that there's a real risk of this
particular statute being
misinterpreted um into um just a broad
allowance of exactly the kind of
behavior that I that I described um most
citizens don't write the laws um most
citizens never read our laws what they
do is they hear about our laws um and um
I have a con I have a I think I have a
legitimate concern that there are going
to be people who
misinterpret this
legislation um and who think they have
the ability to something to do something
that I don't think the people who
drafted this law intend for them to do
so I think that there's a real danger
here of unintended consequence and and I
really think that sometimes we do need
legislators see seeing no further the
hands
raised the matter will now be put the
question if you were in support of the
motion of about the pass as amended
please say yay if you're opposed please
say nay the clerk will now call the role
than chairman Welch hi representative
Bert yes representative Spain yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman
yes representative true yay
representative Pratt yes representative
Marston
yay the clerk votes yes representative
Harry Gaff nay representative Bixby
no Representative o'n
no Representative
bord
no representative Ms
no representative
Newman
no Representative bden no representative
Conley no representative H Knight
no representative Bradley no chairman
the chair votes yes Mr chairman vote is
11 y
10 by vote of 11 Y and 10 y the motion
of ought to pass as amended and
pass will be minor majority
report yes there will
be tonight before 10 o' you be preparing
a Minority
Report thank you very much the at this
time we will now close the executive
196 at this time we're
opening public hearing on House
Bill 557 relative to the authority of
the state and County Correction
facilities displ inmates uh using those
assment
now recognizes represent to offer
introduce
the um thank you Mr chairman I hope you
can hear me okay can hear uh thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
for taking my testimony today my name is
Amanda Balin and I represent Hillsboro
District 12 which is Manchester Ward
five um in introducing House Bill 557 I
just wanted to clarify some terminology
close confinement solitary solitary
confinement um are all the same
generally um they represent the same
ideas um in our state facilities they
refer to it as C5 status but I
anticipate that um the commissioner of
the Department of Corrections um might
testify today as to the difference
between C5 status and what you might
think solitary is based on um tell shows
things like that um so the intent of
this bill is to repeal Antiquated laws
and to preserve the currently accepted
use of solitary confinement in our
facilities um basically bring an update
to the law and put it in line with the
current practice in our
facilities the original law that created
the county prison system in the 1800s um
at the time it was only a County
facility I don't uh we didn't have a
state facility and in the um and it was
in the 1800s that the uh the rsas forked
and we sort of set up a separate uh
County system and a state system that
were run by different bodies and had um
eventually a very different set of laws
um dictating what goes on in those
facilities um so over time they were
recodified and in the last century and a
half the original
[Music]
um the original terminology has been
slowly peeled away by subsequent
legislatures um and right now very
little remains of what was originally
the um the laws for the county
facilities in the
1800s so for
example um the section of law that uh
section two of this bill repeals
originally said um in part if any any
prisoners are refractory and stubborn
and refuse to work or to perform their
work in a proper manner then the
superintendent may put them in close
confinement until they submit to perform
their task and obey his order and in the
case of great obstinacy and perverseness
may reduce them to bread and water till
they submit and Obey so in the 1800s
concepts of um criminal justice and
reform were a little different and you
can see that over time at a minimum if
you've if you've looked the RSA that
section two repeals then you would
observe that the at a minimum the
portion about only feeding prisoners
bread and water has been repealed since
then um and another now repealed section
it's completely gone from the law says
that if any prisoner shall abscond
Escape or depart a house of correction
without license um that they can be
restrained using Fetters or shackles um
so a lot like the um the law against uh
uh adultery that was repealed by this
body um maybe four bium ago um New
Hampshire has a lot of really outdated
laws on the books um the terminology
certainly outdated but so are the
policies um as members of the criminal
justice committee you've probably heard
before that the Quakers are believed to
have originated the concept of solitary
confinement um in the 1800s and I think
in the 1700s as well the Quakers hoped
that by giving someone Solitude and a
Bible and maybe a skylight they could
look to God uh look upward to God and
consider their their
sinfulness and um consider how they
might become better people and this
method became popular because it was
considered it it became popular outside
of Quaker groups um in the nation in
general because it was considered to be
more Humane than public floggings or
hangings um at the time but eventually
the Quakers abandoned the practice when
they noticed that the people that they
were trying to reform so that they could
be productive members of the community
were coming out of their solitary
confinement violent and very different
and they um you know without access to
science and Concepts like that they they
in regardless began to question whether
their program was effective um and keep
in mind when solitary confinement became
popular um popular as a a Humane
alternative to public floggings and
hangings these were people that were
only a couple Generations removed from
the SE and Witch Trials and this was
really before the birth of our nation um
that these were cuttingedge Technologies
for um enacting reform among prisoners
uh so this is certainly under a
different uh system of government um in
a different
Society so so the thing about solitary
confinement is that because mental
health issues often already pre-exist in
so many um offenders it can be really
hard to determine what mental health
issues um an offender is experiencing
that predate imprisonment and predate
solitary confinement and which are the
result of the exposure to solitary
confinement but studies showed that the
majority of those who experien solitary
confinement end up reoffending and at a
higher rate than the overall population
of the
facility um there is an amendment that
the committee should have
received on this bill and it was
proposed by uh the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections um in OS I
guess both I and Os overlooked a portion
that we were striking in section one
went a little heavy with the the Sharpie
there and um it turns out that section
one in part gives the Department of
Correction the um authority to
discipline whatsoever and the intent of
this bill is just to remove solitary
confinement as a method of discipline um
so there's a variety of other ways to
discipline an inmate and um as it turns
out the State Department of Corrections
is not using solitary confinement to
discipline inmates they do use solitary
confinement but for reasons other than
discipline um so if someone is a safety
risk um they're they're at risk of
harming others or maybe others are at
risk of are likely to harm them um there
may be health issues uh the current
pandemic certainly an example of how
isolation can prevent the spread of
disease um so there's a lot of reasons
why solitary confinement has benefits in
uh Correctional institution and probably
in life in general um but as a form of
punishment it's not um a regular
practice anymore and it's not considered
appropriate um but I look forward to
hearing the commissioner's uh testimony
in that regard because I know that she's
um if she does plan on testifying um I
know that she's obviously the authority
on the system that is used in the
facility to determine who's given
solitary confinement and for what reason
and uh how that decision's arrived at um
also there's a misunderstanding that I'd
like to address which is the belief that
section two would repeal the ability for
the County facility to discipline in any
manner um this is not the unfortunately
because section two is a straight repeal
it doesn't print the language in the law
um but you can uh look it up online if
you like um but section two is not what
gives County facilities the authority to
discipline in fact section two very
specifically gives the county
authorities the authority to
discipline when a prisoner refuses to
work so for example in the cafeteria in
the laundry Center um if a prisoner
refuses to work then uh section two
repeals the authority to give them
solitary confinement as a method of
discipline in that situation and that's
one of the laws going back to the 1800s
when typically next to the jail you'd
find a field maybe they'd be building
things um maybe their labor would be
farmed out to nearby businesses as a way
of um paying back their debt to society
and that's not something that's really
going on anymore in
facilities and um the county facilities
have by Statute Ru making Authority
where they can um they can determine how
they will discipline inmates and uh in
in essence section two repeals a sort of
like appendix um it's a section of law
that's not being used anymore it's not
necessary it doesn't really have a
purpose and we've already found
workarounds where we've written new laws
since then that enable the count
facilities to handle issues like this um
in other ways and additionally um
because section to repeals the County's
authority to punish people who refuse to
work you can see that this isn't the the
section of law that gives the counties
the authority to discipline whatsoever
otherwise we would never be able to
discipline people for violence or
attempting to escape because that's not
delineated in the RSA that's repealed in
section two
um so there's a lot of different ways
that someone could be disagreeable or
hard to work with when they're
incarcerated um aside from just refusing
to do
laundry and um because the uh the RSA in
section two was written in the 1800s and
times have changed and so much has
changed in the way that we really do
corrections in on this planet um it's
just outdated the terminology doesn't
work it doesn't fit into their program
anymore um so I think that that's all
that I really wanted to communicate to
the committee I really encourage you to
look up the RSA that's repealed in
section two to get clarification on the
um archaic and outdated and unnecessary
you thank
question has a question thank you Mr
chair and thank the member for taking my
question I actually have three questions
but I'll start with the first one which
is that I do not see an amendment and I
know that I'm substituting on the
committee but um you had mentioned an
amendment which I assume would unstrip
the words and may punish and convict
guilty insolence or ill language to any
officer of the prisons or guilty uh of
obstinate and refractory Behavior period
giving them the ability to punish but
take taking out the method of punishment
but I don't see that amendment in my
packet and I'm just I took everything
that was available and I don't see it so
I'm was wondering if that actually got
drafted and is available to people today
and was going to be offered today or if
it's an
oversight the um thank you for the
question in our committee the committee
assistant emails out amendments to the
list of committee members and I'm
assuming that I don't know how recently
you were assigned to be a sub today but
I'm assuming that um when that went out
you weren't copied but I'd be happy to
send it to you in um whenever we're done
talking um I suppose whenever I'm done
answering questions I can forward that
to you because I can't do that many
things with my brain at once um but the
amendment language was drafted by the
commissioner of the State Department of
Corrections um so I so that way we can
have confidence that it fits in with um
what they're doing at their
facility thank you followups
have a followup question um does this in
any way
impede the Department of Corrections
either at the county level or the state
level from using solitary confinement to
prisoner I think I opened a program on
my computer by accident um no it thank
you for the question it does not impede
um the use of solitary for other
purposes and that kind of goes back to a
lot lot of the rules that we have in
place dictating how our County and state
and prison facilities are run um is is
mostly administrative rules that go
through um Jael car for example and
they're not really in the rsas anymore
and that's kind of what makes this set
of rsas Stand Out is that they speak to
really specific
situations um specific problems with
specific um uh really controlled ways of
addressing them um and that doesn't fit
into the overall scheme of how we're
operating these Correctional
institutions anymore I hope that that
makes sense does and one final follow up
question the last one that I had was uh
in the repeal of section
toly at the county level would this
actually repeal them from being able to
punish in any way for refusing to work
or is this only taking the option of
solitary confinement the list of options
they have for refusing to work because I
know that I still see the prisoners out
collecting trash on the side of the
working I thanks for the question you
broke up a little at the beginning I'm
assuming that's my connection um but I
think that I understood your question
[Music]
um a different RSA in the same uh
section of law gives the county
facilities um Ru making Authority
through the Commissioners and they're
free to set rules for their facilities
um as to how they want to discipline
inmates so I hope that that clarifies
like this that's what really makes this
sort of like the appendix is you're
muted you're muted question
repres yes why did I
mute my other question
that's right it should stay muted um my
other my other part of the question that
you missed when I asked it was does this
actually take away from their ability to
punish or not want them to work or
refusing to work I don't care about all
the other ways they can punish people
for other things they do wrong I don't
want to take away the ability for the
counties to punish people who refuse to
work on work detail because we do still
send people out on work details um and
they should be able to be punished for
there a question there yes I'm asking
does this remove the ability to punish
at
all thanks for the question the answer
is no um I hope that that the way that
I'm phrasing my answer makes sense but
no this does not remove that
Authority thank
you there any other questions from the
committee Mr
chairman Wallace thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um will
this eliminate the practice of close to
term thank you for the question I'm a
little confused can you um you said the
the practice or just the term are you
asking me if I'm cleaning up vocabulary
in the rsas is that what you're asking
question uh thank you Mr chairman well
it's pretty straightforward um looking
at the amendment and looking at the
original bill um and based on what you
said it's unclear to me if this is just
going to eliminate the term close or
solitary confinement and by your
testimony you said it would still be
able to be used for the purpose of
protecting an inmate so the question
remains will this eliminate the practice
of close to solitary confinement for
just the
terminology um thanks for the question I
think my answer is that it does not
eliminate terminology and it does not
eliminate the practice so neither um
because I think there's just a
misunderstanding about the bill in
general the bill does not eliminate the
practice of solitary confinement it
eliminates um it repeals language and
rewrites language that in the 1800s gave
um superintendents and um and leader uh
people running uh Correctional
institutions uh the authority
to um confine people who refuse to work
or to use solitary confinement as a form
of punishment in uh for other activities
and um as I said earlier the Department
of Corrections is not using and when I
say the Department of Corrections I'm
referring to the state facility and then
when I say the um the County facility
I'm referring to the counties so um the
Department of Corrections um at the
state level does not use solitary
confinement as a punishment they use
solitary confinement for protection for
Health um to limit the movement of a
prisoner who's likely to be violent or
um cause other problems in the facility
that warrant uh confinement um they have
a system that I hope when the
commissioner uh speaks she's asked um
about the grading system but they have a
a very thorough grading system set out
in in rules that were approved through
Jael car to determine when um an inmate
should be confined and um as I
understand it multiple staff members are
required to um uh evaluate the prisoner
separately U so that the system can't be
gamed and there can't be someone um to
like prevent someone from who maybe has
a personal problem with an inmate uh to
prevent them
from uh sending someone to solitary as a
punishment when they they just maybe
have a personal problem with them so
multiple people need to be involved in
evaluating The Prisoner there um a
grading system this the prisoners given
certain ratings on certain um on certain
fronts um for example their propensity
for violence things like that the also
was taken into consideration is the
reason that they were incarcerated in
the first place uh the severity of that
crime and those are the criteria that
are used to determine who goes to
solitary and none of the criteria are if
they need to be punished for something
um so the Department of Corrections is
not using uh the is not taking advantage
of what current law allows them to do
and that's one of the reasons behind um
a
clarifies yes thank you Mr chairman um
and if I might ask representative what
bill uh thanks for the question I was
thinking about that today and I couldn't
remember
um but commonly I'm uh searching for
something else on the Gen Court website
and then I stumble across a dumb old law
and I'm like wow this law is dumb and
it's old and uh we should repeal it and
then come September I file a bill um and
that's
usually that's usually how things go um
if you look at if you look up the RSA
that's repealed in section two the uh
terminology is really entertaining
um I guess I don't have it in front
front of me but um refractory stubborn
refuses to submit to work um these are
you know rules words from a different
Society with different
standards and um while there's certainly
documents that were written a very long
time ago that are really important to us
today and we want to preserve them and
continue to live by them um there's
obviously um rules that we like to get
rid of over time as we learned better
for example you know um in the time of
the saale and Witch Trials there was
there were a lot of Concepts and beliefs
that people had back then that were not
accurate lives were lost as a result of
these misunderstandings and it's always
Inc coming upon um a good Society to
evaluate the laws that has in place and
update them and um I'm hoping to follow
in the footsteps of the the commissioner
in um updating uh the the existing laws
to reflect what's actually going on in
our
facilities
me a question yes thank you Mr chair
thank you uh representative for taking
my question um the uh in the uh
Amendment there is a um a line that says
uh that the commissioner may use
appropriate Correctional best practices
in responding to VI violent Behavior es
Escape threats rioting and behavior that
adversely affect safety security or
facility operations are those best
practices going to be part of the uh rul
making
process uh thanks for the question I
believe that they already are and that's
um I think that that the commissioner
looked at this uh bill as an opportunity
to update existing law um to cover
things that probably weren't considered
either weren't considered in the 1800s
or were delineated in areas of law that
have since been repealed I know that um
when this little snippet on
um solitary if you refuse to work was
put into place um there was also that
little bit about um if you're really
fussy we'll only feed you bread and
water and then there was also at the
time another section of law that dealt
with um how to handle people who try to
escape what happens to them once they're
captured um who's to pay for the
resources necessary to find them and all
of that's been repealed since then um so
that that is covered in other areas of
law now and it's just I mean in their
rule making um process and it's just
necessary to update the law to reflect
that okay uh so followup I just I just
want to make Absol absolutely clear that
the that what what's going to be going
into statute is pretty pretty General
and I just want to make sure that
there's going to be very much something
much more specific in the
rules there is yeah thank thank
you all right see I see no other hands
up on the
committee thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you John who do we
chairman Mr chairman if they could raise
their hand if they
are
yeah the members of of the public if
someone's out there and want to speak ah
we have one
hel
welcome good afternoon honorable members
of the committee again this is Helen
Hanks the commissioner of the Department
of Corrections for the record I am in my
office with the door closed alone I
thank representative Balden for bringing
this piece of legislation forward you'll
see me signed in opposed my opposition
was to the original Bill not to the
proposed amendment as we did work
collaboratively on trying to provide
some current language representative of
the State of New Hampshire and I
appreciate the adjustment because we are
a rehabilitative organization and we
should be using appropriate Correctional
best practices and to representative
bixby's comment we want to be careful
not to
overprescribed in law and not be able to
grow as a state department of
corrections as those practices adjust
but if you if you do the research when
you do the research I know you will as
you are likely have done before today uh
you'll find things like the Department
of Justice published guidelines on the
use of uh restrictive housing so the
term solitary confinement we don't use
that term in state corrections you'll
see in my testimony has submitted at the
beginning of this week or it could have
been last week I do lose track of time
at the pace in which we work here in the
state of New Hampshire that we Chang
significantly as far back as 2005 with
regard to our practices as a result of
very appropriate cases brought forward
and those practices have have not
changed um in fact when you when you go
to sites such as the national Commission
on Correctional healthc care American
Corrections Association when they Define
those practices it's 22 hours or more
locked in a Cell we haven't engaged in
that practice in more than a decade and
and nor should any Correctional agency
do so in the future um those
classification rules as represented
Balden reference those are available all
under the correctional rules chapter 400
talk about how we analyze and assess
individuals um with regard to the
section of law here uh discipline when
representative Bolan and I first
discussed this I had not realized that I
had agreed to striking all my authority
to engage in discipline so I want to
appreciate her publicly for allowing me
to make sure we maintain safe
Correctional institutions for the men
and women incarcerated in the state of
New
Hampshire and I would also point you to
RSA 21 h13 rul making it described all
the rul making requirements of the state
agency and we have been updating those
rules and moving them forward both at
the beest of this committee and other
members of the department and
constituent groups um you'll find that
in section 21 h14 however we've asked to
make and you have maintained this uh
privilege under law that the behavior of
and it's the term in law inmates is not
prescribed in rule writing and I just
want to point out to you for example the
agency has to be nimble in response to
the activities within the agency and to
try to engage in rule writing to predict
Behavior would be a significant
challenge most recent example is we have
individuals who are remitting letters on
K2 soaked paper I would not have
predicted that six months ago so we have
to engage in behavior and discipline
standards for that type of activity it's
both adverse to our residents and
obviously the introduction of
contrabands such as substance substance
es of abuse create for um inappropriate
environments with people under the use
of those elicit substan substances so
I'm careful that the discipline rendered
should be rehabilitative in nature the
behavior needs to be the behavior
guidelines which are published internal
procedures and certainly available to
the public are available and people
understands understand what those
standards are so we're
clear uh again I know this committee has
likely read my testimony I would rather
uh give you an afford you the
opportunity to ask questions and follow
up with any additional information but I
believe the proposed amendment helps the
seate of New Hampshire and the
Department of Corrections get to more
appropriate language representative 2021
committee thank you very much for your
testimony
[Music]
uh Mr chairman I don't see any I do see
four phones uh listed here I don't know
if they're just listening or I think it
is if uh representative Muse could help
me I think it's star nine Mr chair to
raise your hand with a telephone Chelsea
Manny Chelsea Manny signed up to testify
and I see her
online I believe it's star six
representative B oh okay because I know
there was one for you know mute and one
for raising the hand so if one of the
phone people do want to speak if they
could press star six or nine I know one
of
it yes I see Chelsea
Manning two
minutes whoops where did she go oh there
she
is bring her back allowed to talk for
Miss man or Miss
man unmute okay uh thank you members of
this committee uh good afternoon I am
Chelsea Manning I am a security
consultant researcher in machine
learning and artificial intelligence I'm
also an activist for incarcerated people
and for unionizing in the workplace uh
previously I spent seven years in prison
following a high-profile Court Marshal
um I was uh sentenced to 35 years uh and
subsequently I was commuted uh by
President Obama um for another year uh a
few years later I was uh confined for uh
one more year uh for uh civil uh for
civil civil confining uh for resisting a
Federal grand jury subpoena to compel uh
testimony um in the Years uh that I've
spent uh in in total I have spent 403
years uh in various forms of isolated
confinement uh including administrative
segregation maximum security
disciplinary segregation the the entire
Gambit of uh various types of uh of
confinement uh and and its different
names um used by uh the prison system in
the United States um and uh on uh in in
20 in both 2010 and again in uh 2019 uh
my uh conditions were investigated by
the United sta by the United Nations
special rapor on torture uh subsequently
there was a report done uh that uh that
designated that uh fif that
approximately uh that anytime that you
have 15 days or more of uh
um of uh so of confinement U that is
more than that that is any any time
period of around 22 hours per day uh uh
in isolation uh would be considered
torture by the United Nations um in the
years since uh my confinement I have uh
developed complex PTSD I have been in
years and years of therapy I have
difficulty with relationships even with
people before confinement and this is
despite having a full-time job uh and a
lot of resources a lot of access to the
public uh and whatnot um so I I only
longterm consequential effects to um to
being held in isolation and this this
type form of confinement and I just want
you to consider that uh the long-term
effects um that this has you know
whether whe whether it's for any reason
whatsoever it has it significantly
impacts one's life far beyond um
actually being uh he in confinement um
and uh and uh just imagine the res you
know people that don't have the
resources uh and the access um that I
the incredible access to these resources
that I have
had um must go through um that is that
is the that is the end of my testimony
thank you very much
members you've had your two minutes we
thank you be a testimony are there any
committee I see
testimony Mr chairman I see no further
hands or uh telephones with their hands
up I do see four telephones
listening and I guess we will put to
public hearing on up
557 uh
hands
up hands is
up
who
yes you have a question actually it's I
have not yet received the amendment to
this uh bill is it possible to get the
again it I received one very quickly
from Brad so you might get it right a
few minutes representa M would you uh do
the
honors yes uh for House Bill 557 we had
101 uh people signing in in support and
we had four people sign in in
that um one of the four was um
commissioner Hanks and she retracted
that it should be 102 to oppose three
all right we will close the hearing on
557 be in recess
until
2:30
up at this time we are opening the
123 granting immunity from prosecution
for prosecution for reporting a sexual
assault uh that will also be heard with
House
Bill
546 relative to 911 immunity for
reporting that a person has been a
crime representative I see your hand is
raised
yes I can just barely hear what you're
saying I don't know if the mics are not
uh all active or something because I
could just barely hear you Mr chair the
chair does have uh his own microphone
right in front of
him that's on I uh do the other members
at home are having any trouble hearing
me I'm having trouble hearing you here
but not now I think the mic was just
away from you Mr
chairman can can the members hear me yes
uh can you can you hear me better now or
[Music]
you representative kly night will you be
introducing House Bill
123 um yes thank you chair you're now
recognized thank you um House Bill 123
is um a repeat from last year it passed
with consent 19 to
zero um it was worked on by both
representative Welch and representative
uh panelas last term and um there is
going to be an amendment introduced uh
by by I hope hopefully by our chair um
so I I'm not sure if I should speak to
that or we should wait till exec session
but I just wanted to get that on your
radar and that would make the bill um a
little stronger for victims that are
um they they they shouldn't have to
prove that they're victims in that
moment to receive Medical care so that's
what the amendment does um and we had
for people that weren't in the committee
last year really compelling stories of
women um not just women but um mostly
from women being held basically prisoner
and being raped
repeatedly under the guys that they
couldn't leave and get themselves the
help that they needed um because that
they were conducting in a form of a
prostitution so it's used by harassers
um to keep their
victims compliant and that means we get
less reports for crimes on these issues
as well so uh I'll again um hopefully
this this makes it pass this time and
questions
being No Hands raised I want to thank
the representative for testimony and
just to clarify representative
representative night if you do wish to
ask any questions uh you will be
permitted to ask questions but if you do
specifically only in regards to House
Bill 546 so please when you if you do
ask a
question open the question by saying
specifically regards the house bill
546 thank you for the
clarification
[Music]
representative Balden will you be
introducing House Bill
546 yes you are now recognized and that
that same introduction in regards I just
same statement I made to representative
F night would apply to you but in
regards to how app
for um thank you Mr chairman thank you
Comm for hearing my testimony again
today um on House Bill 546 so this is a
bill that came through this committee um
before coid and it uh never made it
through the Senate because of the
pandemic um I believe it was voted 18
to2 um ought to pass um originally and
was on the consent calendar at the time
and um for what it's worth the bill that
was just heard was I believe unanimously
passed by this committee before coid and
was on consent um both of the bills
operate on the back of the
same the concept that already exists in
New Hampshire law um I know that the
makeup of this committee has changed a
lot but one thing that's stayed the same
more or less over the years has been the
presence of uh representative John Bert
and he would surely remember sitting
through the
subcommittee meetings on the 911
immunity um law that we were trying to
pass back then and I think the the
chairman of the subcommittee was a
legislator who's not here anymore I
think um renie Cushing was on the
subcommittee and so was representative F
and the focus of that subcommittee was
what to do with a proposal to give
immunity to people um for the possess
for the charge of drug possession if the
evidence for that charge is found when
they report an overdose and something
that um 911 Personnel were running into
at the time was bodies in snowbanks and
bodies in alone in rooms with just a
driver's license left and all the drug
paraphernalia cleaned out and the
problem at the time was that um people
would unfortunately when faced with the
choice between um getting their their
friend if you want to call it that
medical help when they're overdose
overdosing or um saving themselves they
would save themselves more often than
not and um so
ultimately um when Governor Hassen um
was governor uh Senator hen was governor
um the a republican Le House and Senate
passed a law to give immunity um for the
charge of possession if the evidence is
found when someone's calling 911 to
report an overdose
so there's it's a really well-written
area of Law and this bill just amends
that area of law to include um immunity
from the charge of possession if you're
reporting a violent crime in general and
then the bill references a specific list
of violent crimes um and uh so the way
that the existing law works is if you
call the police and you say I'm
reporting an overdose and they show up
and there's people tied up in your
basement you're going to get in trouble
for that and if they show up and you
have a meth lab you're going to get in
trouble for that but if they show up and
you have um such a small amount of drugs
on you or drug paraphernalia that it
only qualifies for the charge of
possession then you're not going to get
in trouble for that and the goal is to
encourage with the existing law
encourage people to communicate with
police and communicate with 911 and save
people's lives so that they have the
opportunity to turn their lives around
I've certainly met people who've been
who've gotten Naran five six seven times
in their lives and they're now pastors
or youth leaders and they finally had
the opportunity to turn their lives
around and the data um the the law that
was originally passed had a sunset in it
and there was
a GOP bill in um a subsequent year to
repeal the sunset because data was
showing that the existing law was very
effective and encouraging people to call
911 in the uh event of an overdose so
what I had in mind with this bill and
what I communicated to the committee
last year was that we should extend that
to people who are um either have been
victimized themselves or may have
information that they'd like to share
with police about a crime um because as
we know from at a minimum watching
gangster movies um that oftentimes in
certain um
communities there's it's less important
that someone's committed a crime and
more important that you maintain your
freedom from um you know jail or
something like that and people are not
willing to communicate with police and
there's so many articles on the Union
Leader Manchester inklink and so forth
where Manchester police that's where I
live are um complaining that there are
people showing up at the Elliott
hospital with stab wounds gunshot wounds
they won't talk they won't tell anyone
what happened and how are they supposed
to address that these are real victims
of a crime there's someone who's
committed a crime who's walking around
free and it's because there's something
going on in the victim's life life that
they're not willing to cooperate with
police and for whatever reason they've
decided that they'd rather um that the
person who hurt them go free than have
to interact with police because of
whatever's going on
and interestingly enough um we heard
this bill well your committee our
committee I'm on the committee now heard
this bill um January of 2020 before the
house really shut down over coid and um
at the time you know I was proposing
this bill based on complaints that I'd
seen in the news where people weren't
cooperating with police and just that it
seemed common sense that if someone's
willing to cooperate with police to
report information about a bank robbery
that they'd overheard someone bragging
about or if they wanted to report that
they'd been assaulted or abused in some
way raped or something like that it just
seemed like common sense that someone um
shouldn't be arrested if the thing
they're being arrested for is just
really small and insignificant it
doesn't involve a victim um
but then interestingly enough uh it was
probably like three or four weeks into
um like I guess what I would call Peak
coid you know sometime in March um we
came home from getting groceries which
we were only doing about every two weeks
at the time and turned the corner near
our house and there were two men on the
side of the road in the grass fighting
and my husband uh I was the passenger my
husband pulled over and started honking
like telling them stop it you know he's
just reacting like what do we do but we
can't just drive past this you know this
isn't New York you you don't just drive
past something like that in New
Hampshire and um so he pulled over he's
honking he's yelling at them and we look
closer and the guy who was on top had a
full champagne bottle in his hand and
was beating the other guy in the face
and there was blood everywhere it was
horrifying and um let of you know me I'm
a little nuts I got out of the car and
the guy who's um on top with the
champagne bottle leaves and we were in
touch with 911 at the time and they said
that they were coming and I'm saying to
this guy who has blood all down his face
down his clothes all over the things
he's carrying I'm like please wait uh
there's an ambulance coming you probably
need stitches he seemed to be in shock
and he just walked away like into our
neighborhood in the direction we were
going so I followed him
and I was like my husband's just going
to keep driving behind us he knows me
he's not going to talk me out of this if
you're walking this way guess what we're
going to pass by my house we can get you
some paper towels and I was trying to
reason with him and I was like please
just wait for the ambulance um you might
have a concussion you shouldn't go to
sleep if you have a concussion Etc and I
could tell based on how he was dressed
and the things he was carrying that he
might not have a place to live um and he
repeatedly said to me I don't want to
talk to the police I don't want to
interact with them
um I I don't want the police around me I
don't want them in my life I'm not going
to talk to the cops you need to leave me
alone lady um and I refused and then uh
somewhere along our long walk through my
neighborhood um the police caught up to
us and eventually an ambulance and I um
said to the police will you please um
don't give them a hard time because I
guess something's going on and you know
um he doesn't want to interact with you
and uh anyway later on because we were
Witnesses the police called me and and
asked me if I would uh give my statement
over the phone as to what happened so
that they could pursue the person who
was Vally caught and arrested for
assault and they told me that the person
who was um assaulted refused to
cooperate um so I was the only person
who could really speak to what had
happened that day aside from my husband
and it's just funny how um you know I
put in the bill and then a couple months
later when Co had had already eaten the
bill or the Senate you know um wasn't
going to take it up as they did with so
many pieces of legislation last year
it's funny that I would walk right into
a situation and basically live out the
concepts in this bill um so I'm happy to
take any questions about how it's worded
I'm sure the bill looks a little complex
but in a
reality it's just uh tapered onto um the
edges of the existing law that relate to
um calling in an overdose and the you
know again the idea here is for someone
to be able to call in um information
they have about a burglary a robbery a
violent crime against another person um
if they've been victimized for them to
be able to report that and feel
comfortable doing so um so I think
that's all I wanted to share with the
questions thank you representative for
your testimony if you don't mind the
chair would like inquire of a question
on on the bill line six and then again
on line
n it uses the the another
person so is this intended to apply when
someone themselves is a victim of a
violent
crime and they wish to report the crime
because if it says another person
wouldn't that
exclude individual call on their their
own behalf when they are the
victim thanks for the question so
section two um or Roman two refers to
another person and r R 3 refers to the
person
reporting so Roman 3 um 17 line 17 in
good faith in a timely manner reports
that he or she has been a victim of a
violent crime or is the victim in a good
faith in timely report of a violent
crime so the ideas that the um the
caller and the subjects of the crime are
covered the idea being that um you know
someone might be reporting a rape or an
assault or something but they might also
be reporting
um a theft and maybe the the victim of
the theft isn't even present maybe you
know someone uh breaks into my house and
steals something and uh then they brag
and someone else hears about it and then
that person would call in by themselves
so they would be personally covered um
but then
also um you know if someone's personally
victimized and maybe there's also a
witness to that incident um then either
the person who's victimized or the
person who witnesses it could call in I
hope that
clarifies it does it did raise so but we
can talk about the rest on the executive
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
representative is
excused uh if any members of the public
who are in attendance who wish to
hands testimony to the members of the
public will be limited to two
minutes the chair now
recognizes Dr Joe
Hannon and for the witnesses please
specify uh which would testifying on
behalf of HB 123 or 546 or
both uh thank you Mr chairman my name is
Joe Hannon uh former legislator retired
doctor and um I'm testifying in favor of
both bills one two three House Bill one
two3 and the uh five
46 um I I was around for I was in the
legislature when the original 911
immunity bill came through and was uh
helpful and help getting that passed in
some way with many of you on this
committee and I'm glad to see that this
has gone to a different level I
regularly work with people doing syringe
exchange and in the recovery Community
who have been victims of uh violent
crimes or or even sexual assaults and
have not reported these crimes I've
actually personally witnessed people
being assaulted or sexually assaulted
not witness sexual assault but witness
people being assaulted or um being the
victims of sexual assault and I've
treated some of these people medically
in some of my training in the past um
none of them that I've met wanted to
come forward and and file charges and
prosecute the people who had assaulted
or sexually abuse them because of fear
of uh retaliation for either drugs or
prostitution
predominantly uh I it's it's also very
uh clear that uh sex workers in general
are very reluctant to forward as are all
victims of sexual violence we know that
the numbers of people who actually come
forward and report sexual violence are
are dismally low it's in the the teens
in in many studies that you look at of
how many people actually report these
crimes and in in instances of people in
the sex work industry that's even lower
I think we need these laws uh
desperately to keep people safer and not
just protect people who are using drugs
and sex workers but to protect other
victims uh who may be victimized by
people who were not put in jail because
they victimized someone who just
happened to be doing drugs or in sex
work so this doesn't just protect them
it protects society as a whole and I
implore you to please pass both of these
go it's the first time you made it up in
two
[Music]
minutes representative uh representative
question thank you chair
um and I'm speaking on House Bill
546 thank you for taking my question um
Do You Believe by introducing this kind
of legislation you'll see a reduction in
crime um I don't know if I I mean I'd
hope so but I I definitely think you'll
see uh an increase in reporting of
crimes which could lead to to less
crimes being perpetrated in the future I
think people are less likely to commit a
crime if they know that that victim is
not afraid to come forward so yes I do
think that will may be the case in many
followup repres night you recognized for
a followup question thank you um do you
think there's potential then
for more data gathering on this
subject oh absolutely I right now we
don't hear anything I mean even just
people who are not uh in the sex work
field or using drugs don't come forward
in such high numbers we don't know about
a lot of these uh specifically sexual
assaults um most people are are more
inclined to report an assault in simple
assault or a battery assault and battery
if they're not involved in those those
areas but I think this will definitely
increase um the the bring it to light
light is the best disinfectant so people
being able to come forward definitely
will help solve some of the
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness again for his
Lynn yep she's unmuted Mr
chair
or hi good afternoon Mr chairman this is
Lynn
chalette you can hear you okay wonderful
thank you so much good afternoon Mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Lynn chalette and I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence and I'm here to speak in
support of House Bill 123 thank you for
this
opportunity we fundamentally believe
that the fear of being arrested should
never prohibit any victim from reporting
that they have been sexually assaulted
um and this protection should apply to
any rape victim including those who have
engaged in prostitution tion we
generally support this legislation
including the amendment that was
referenced by the sponsor in her opening
comments um and I'd like to touch um
just for a few minutes on that specific
language less than two minutes um the
reason that we support this amendment is
the bill as drafted currently violates
the spirit and the letter of the law of
the federal violence against women act
the violence against women act is a
federal statute that grants funding
rights and protection to victims of
Domestic and Sexual ual
violence specifically when vow was
passed in 2005 it includes language that
prohibits States from requiring victims
to participate in the criminal justice
system or to cooperate with law
enforcement in order to be eligible to
receive Medical Care and forensic
evidence collection so the Coalition
would support an amendment that removes
two pieces of language in this bill
first removing the requirement that
provides that a victim must cooperate in
an investigation that's in the
legislative intent and also in section 7
removing the language that requires a
victim to assist law enforcement to
identify the
perpetrator the goal of the violence
against women Act was to make sure that
any person who's sexually assaulted is
able to get critical Medical Care
screening and evidence collection
victims face so many barriers when they
come forward to report a rape or to
report domestic violence and it's
critical that this state legislation
mirror the protections provided to
victims on the federal level to ensure
sure that they have access to that care
so I appreciate the opportunity to come
before you today um
and I bet that's my timer so thank you
very much for for your support and
consideration
today I want to thank you again for your
testimony representative true you
recognized thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh
eight of the bill I don't understand it
um victim seeking medical
treatment uh doesn't need to make a
enforcement if somebody's going to a
hospital in need of medical
treatment aren't they going to get
medical treatment at the
hospital or is the is the doctor at the
hospital going to say must cooperate
with law enforcement before I treat you
I I don't I don't understand that whole
scenario right um thank you for your
question representative so the scenario
that we're concerned about is if someone
who is sexually assaulted comes forward
and in the process of receiving that
care tells the doctor or tells the nurse
or the sexual assault nurse examiner
that they were engaged in prostitution
when they were sexually assaulted we the
goal of this bill is to make sure that
that individual can still receive the
care and the evidence collection if they
want it and that they won't be at risk
of being arrested for engaging in
prostitution because they reported a
rape so the scenario you're describing
is exactly what we want to prevent we
want to make sure that any evidence
that's collected or any statement that a
victim makes about engaging in
prostitution is not used as evidence in
them seeing no further hands raised I
want to thank the witness for her
much at this time the chair recognizes
Joseph
Eber good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Joe Ebert it's
EBT I'm a captain with the New Hampshire
State Police I oversee the Investigative
Services Bureau so thank you very much
for giving me the opportunity to speak
today um I want to say say that uh I
will be speaking to
546 uh and 546 only and I I want to
start by saying that we absolutely uh as
a division of State Police support the
notion of of what's trying to be
accomplished uh but as we reviewed this
the one thing I wanted to bring to the
attention of the committee is it does
not appear as though there is a
restriction on the amount of Narcotics
that uh somebody could be um not
prosecuted for so in other words I when
the bill was introduced there was
discussion about a small amount of drugs
uh I think everyone can understand why a
small amount of drugs is uh is clearly
not outweighed by somebody's um Health
um and not that a large amount
necessarily is but there with there no
being no top end on that uh that was uh
something that we wanted to bring
forward to the committee uh to at least
uh have a discussion point that perhaps
there should be some limitation on the
amount of Narcotics that you could be
forgiven for possession um in this given
scenario um so having said that thank
you so much for the opportunity to uh to
address you today and I'm certainly
willing to take any questions that you
may
have I want to thank you for your
testimony representative
G thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um do do you have um
an amount in mind that you were thinking
about I don't ma'am um thank you for the
uh uh the question I I don't I I simply
wanted to bring forward as a a point of
discussion it's it's an incredibly
difficult topic to um try and weigh out
you know the uh the value of reporting
harm that has been done to somebody uh
and and giving somewhat of a free pass
on a possession of some level of drugs
I'm not sure what that uh where that
break even point is um or if it exists I
I simply wanted to bring forward to the
uh the committee for uh discussion that
topic thank
you representative expain you recognize
thank you Mr chair and I thank you for
taking my question um this is not uh
this bill is not replacing the uh the
ACT we already passed that um gives
somebody the ability to report a drug
overdose with immunity um I would
imagine that we already addressed the
situation of a quantity in that act did
we not and um would there be no problem
modeling this after after
that and Sir that may be a question that
is best answered by the other members of
the committee I think it's a a valid
point certainly um but again as a topic
of discussion Perhaps it is something
that was already meet it out through the
process of committee work before I'm not
aware of what that committee work was on
Bill representative Klein night
recognize for a
question thank you um thank you for
taking my question um I believe the
sponsor this is about HB 546 excuse me
uh I believe the sponsor representative
Balden said that um there's certain
limitations already in this bill and
that you know there's certain things
that you can go after someone for and I
just want to know in your experience
when you go to someone that's really a
danger are more often than not aren't
there other crimes that you can find to
go after them
for I so I answer both parts of your
question um and perhaps representative B
I note uh that she did reference that I
didn't when I looked at the bill itself
it seemed to reference 318 B2 I looked
up 318 B2 and it talked about possession
and possession with intent so I I didn't
see I I know that she had said a a small
amount and that's that's why I was
referencing um everyone can I think
everyone can understand a small amount
of drugs is not nearly worth uh taking a
risk at somebody's Health um but I
didn't see within that that bill where
there was um a quantity that was
regarded as being forgiven for lack of a
better term so that may be somewhere
else so and I apologize greatly if I if
I've missed that but I didn't see it
within the bill um and in terms of uh
when we respond to a call and whether or
not there is a um there could be another
crime that could be charged um you know
what I would say is you you it's been my
experience that when I uh respond to
calls or when I'm in the presence of
others who respond calls um we charge
people with the the crimes that they've
committed um and we aren't we aren't
there to to search for necessarily a
just a crime uh to charge so I it is
what you're presented with um at that
time representative Klein now you have a
followup question yeah I'm just I'm just
trying to know what your rights are as
well thank you so it's let just a
scenario you go in there some somebody
called 911
and uh they have some possession on them
and you can't convict them for that and
you save the life but if you think
something else nefarious is going on in
this home when you look
around are you allowed to pursue a
warrant or another Avenue of of
conviction for somebody that is a
criminal yeah absolutely if there
probable cause that exist as you enter a
dwelling to lead you to believe that a
crime has been committed you can
absolutely uh apply for a warrant um I
think what I was uh getting at was was
more uh if you were to uh walk into a
home and there was say uh 25 to 30 kilos
of uh methamphetamine sitting in the the
home is there a provision within this
bill that says uh that then again I may
not be aware of and I apologize if I've
wasted the committee's time on that but
is there a provision Within this bill
that says well at that level at 30 kilos
there uh there could be a criminal
repercussion to this uh but but
absolutely once once you're uh on in a
in a premisis and you're uh you know you
may see evidence of another crime you
could certainly seek a warrant but I
think that uh the from what I understand
from this bill I wouldn't be able to
crime
representative Spain you recognized
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
um in a a little bit of research uh I
think I found the answer to my question
to you previously would you believe that
there was a Supreme Court case State of
New Hampshire versus Brian Eldridge that
was decided on February 19th 2020 in
which the court has decided that the
immunity afforded by RSA 318b
28b 2017 which is the drug immunity that
this is modeled after the immunity did
not extend to possession with intent to
sell and that the Supreme Court has
already decided that the immunity covers
drug amounts that up are up to but not
including amounts that would be of that
quantity to be considered intent to
sell representative Spain I thank you
greatly for uh for finding that case uh
we were certainly not aware of that and
that very much may answer the uh the
concern that we had reference the
quantity that could be available if if
you need to know the name again it is
State of New Hampshire versus Brian
Eldridge and you could be free to look
sir see oh representative Rose thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question I have a very good friend
that's in law enforcement and he was
giving me just you know some examples of
some some of the ways along the lines
that you're that you're addressing as
far as you know possible limits instead
of it just
being I guess just unlimited um would
you be able to give an example of maybe
unintended consequence of what is meant
to be a good thing however when you go
into a home and you know there's just
bad things happening pretty much
everywhere and now as you just said that
you know you're only there for this
particular reason you see all these
things and now your your hands are kind
of tied would you be able to give us
like an example of maybe what you could
see as an unattended consequence of of
that or of this particular
bill so I think where this bill only
addresses the uh possession of a a
narcotic and as representative Spain is
U uh has mentioned uh it appears to be
limited via the Supreme Court to only uh
simple possession I I wouldn't worry as
much uh representative rhods about being
handcuffed by this particular Bill uh
and the reason I say that is um because
it is specific to narcotics and if I
were to see evidence or any other law
enforcement officer were to see evidence
of another crime that was being
committed um they could either act on
what is in plain view or they could uh
certainly seek a warrant and further the
investigation that
you
represent representative true thank you
Mr chair and thank you very much for
taking my question uh if I just throw a
scenario at you so I can get my head
around the
bill especially given what I've heard is
there may be a a court case saying it
only involves simple
possession if it only involves simple
possession then what what is this bill
doing somebody's been
hurt uh I've Got Drugs on me but just
drugs if I call the police cuz somebody
got hurt you're probably not going to
put me up against the wall and search me
you're not going to find the drugs on me
anyway if I just got simple amounts for
simple
possession so so what what does this
what does what does the bill accomplish
uh why wouldn't somebody call for simple
possession they wouldn't call if they've
got a whole bunch of drugs in their
house and they'd be liable for that but
but for simple possession wouldn't a
normal person go ahead and call police
call on
ambulance well what I what I would say
to that sir is sometimes um individuals
who are
U ingesting narcotics don't don't make
the clearest decisions um and I think
that what this uh Bill if I understand
the aim of the bill is um to ensure that
people uh know that they're what
regardless if they're nervous or not
about the small amount of uh drugs that
they have on them that they they are
calling to report that uh that uh
assault or o overdose and that's
certainly Something That We're
supportive of we would never want
somebody to um for the sake of a very
small amount of drugs uh put somebody
else's Health in in
danger thank
you
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
thank you officer for your testimony
thank
you at this time the chair recognizes
Katherine
here um thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee this is
Katherine Cooper appearing on behalf of
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers um I'm speaking
solely to
hb123 and we oppose this bill um we
oppose this bill because it invites
false
accusations um the bill creates an
actual statutory defense to the crime of
prostitution um it does not simply limit
the Gathering of evidence during a
medical exam um the bill is structured
in such a way that anytime a prostitute
is arrested he or she can claim claimed
that they were sexually assaulted and
charges can no longer be
brought so um we request that this bill
be ited because it will invite false
accusations have unjust consequences and
not actually help people who are working
trits seeing No Hands raised I wanted
thank the witness for a
testimony thank you are there any
members of the public who wish to
testify that have not testified already
hands seeing No Hands raised this time
we will close the public hearing on
546 represent M would you like to do the
546 on House Bill
123 we had 106 people sign in in support
and three people sign in in
opposition and on House Bill five uh 46
we had 87 people signed in in support
news the members at home we are going to
open some executive sessions now it will
be highly recommended that you turn on
devices
this time we're opening the executive
123 Community for prosecutions of
prosecution reporting a sexual
assault chair recognizes representative
welon with the motion of to pass and off
an
amendment I make a motion of to pass for
house go 123 and I offer amendment
07608 is there a second I'll
second that has been seconded by
representative
Blain wish to speak to
motion are you offering an amendment we
speak the amendment I'm offering the
amendment and
this what the amendment does in this my
interpretation of it again it's 202-
070 is that if a cruit or a sex worker
were to
report
a a violent crime to
police that sex worker would be required
to Cooper with the investigation they
basically would not have a choice this
this eliminates that requirement U I
know when this bill was presented last
term that was a concern that I raised uh
I know it was also brought to our
attention that that may also being
conflict with federal
law that conflict aside I didn't I still
don't believe that that's a good policy
to compel someone before force a
cooperate investigation and essentially
they could under some circumstance they
could lose the option having immunity by
failing to cooperate and I I I don't
feel that that's voluntary the idea is
that the person's been a victim of a
violent crime regardless of you know
lifestyle or any anything about that no
one deserves to be a victim of violent
crime and uh and also being forced to
the police compelled to testify uh to
cooperate I don't believe is uh I
understand the logic
of reports a crime to a police officer
but law enforcement that is presuming
that person would cooperate that is not
always the case however this amendment
would would would remove that remove
that requirement with they cooperate but
also apparently make it in compliance
with
Federal representative B thank you Mr
chairman
and I guess I'm just wondering on what
Miss Cooper said about if a
prostitute ended up getting arrested he
or she depending on who it is um could
say oh right and you know then the other
person is going to go up river is that a
so believe that goes the under so the
underlying Bill not the amendment but oh
that's true my just to answer that I did
have that in my notes uh so it is the
intent of the general court to encourage
a victim of sexual assault to report
such crimes so my understanding that
this in that scenario the the concern
raised I be by the testimony was someone
is arrested for solicitation
prostitution and then all of a sudden
they say well I was a victim of sexual
assault and they're using that as a
shield in this what this law does is
that the sex workers report rep in the
crime so in order to invoke this they
would be have to report the crime and
therefore so they're already claiming
that they were a victim of sexual
assault before they ever were in custody
or arrested or anything that's my
understanding what the intent of this
does but that's more the underly bill
rather than
the okay yeah we can discuss that for
yes I'll talk about it on the bill I do
apologize I forgot we're just on the
amendment representative cther Okay so
you took out the piece here where it
says an assisting law enforcement to
identify alleged perpetrator that was
line 10 and 11 can you give me the
rationale behind
that so there's two rationals one the
testimony we
heard is that there's a federal law
apparently that does not permit the
requirement that a victim of a violent
crime cooperate with law enforcement
order to obtain medical treatment I hope
I'm working that correctly I'm going off
memory
that's the that's that's the federal law
issue that issue aside of what this law
would require is that if if a sex worker
or who's the victim of the violent crime
were to report that they've been a
victim to law
enforcement uh they are then they
required to then cooperate with the
entire investigation all the way through
now that doesn't mean that they if
they're served with a summons to appear
in court that they can ignore the
summons it just in order to claim the
immunity they shouldn't be required to
continue to cooperate with law
enforcement uh that's I may appear
counterproductive to report a crime can
not cooperate with the investigation but
at the same time should that person lose
the immunity Claim by failing to
cooperate no but I think that the person
the peror you
perpetrator excuse
me listen I agree that they should but
I'm saying by making a requirement that
they do in order to to maintain their
immunity to me it's no longer
voluntary I mean now it's now they're
doing it in exchange not being
prosecuted the're the ones that called
the first place this is just a requiring
to do that but I I do believe that and I
I was opposed to that provision before I
realized it federal law
so it kind of it's on both grounds that
that but I hope I hope if someone does
report that they do
cooperate represent expain thank you Mr
chair if I could I'd like to maybe throw
out a scenario that I've been thinking
of here that might explain why they
might not want to identify the the
perpetrator after they've reported the
crime um would you agree that this
amendment makes it now um
Freer for the person who reports the
crime to say report the crime and then
at some point after they've reported the
crime and they've got their immunity
realized that the person that they got
assaulted by had connections to say the
Whitey buer family and that their life
was in extreme danger if they were to
continue with the identification and
they might become afraid and not want to
report it and this would then allow them
to say you know I've made my report but
I'm not going to go any fur further and
immunity it it would it would extend to
that that scenario and and
that that's a great example but at the
same time even much lesser examples it's
just out of whatever fear that they may
have I believe it's an option that they
don't they not requireed again that
doesn't mean the police can't summons
them as a witness and if that person
doesn't appear the trial the case is not
going to go anywhere compation Clause
would be require the charge to be
dropped represent
TR thank you Mr
fog so I I'll make up the scenario
obviously a scenario type of
guy a prostitute is working in the
streets and she sees two beat cops
coming their way coming her way and
she's obviously working and she says
thank goodness you're here officer I was
just sexually assaulted by who many of
your business I was just sexually
assaulted I don't want to do anything
else to let you know that maybe I should
hospital she's not going to be arrested
for
prostitution she doesn't have to say who
assaulted her
and she gets the medical attention she
she may or may not need
but she gets away with the
crime by following this law two
things to the point that you're making
that again relates to the underly bill
not the amendment so I I guess what my
point is I can address that now maybe we
we vote on the amendment if the
amendment that point would
apply whether the amendment is adopted
or not the underly law but the just
because someone has immunity does not
mean they can never be prosecuted law
enforcement is able to gather evidence
independently of the person reporting
the crime they could still arrest and
prosecute that person they just won't be
able to use the evidence they obtain by
the sex worker
reporting the sexual assault to law
enforcement so the scenario you're
saying where they're you know a sex work
is standing outside and two officers
walk up if they had independent evidence
that whether surveillance whatever they
whether they
claim try to get Immunity on this or
not I don't believe would protect them
from being able to they still could be
arrested because the evidence was obtain
independent
evence but again that's the underlying
Bill even with the with or without the
amendment
so
we can discuss that more maybe after to
we vot on the amend representative
represent true so so the the amendment
itself says cooperation is not
required
bden thank you Mr chairman I understand
that um there's some debate over whether
we can discuss the rest of the bill when
discussing um the amendment um and I and
I hope that it's okay to debate the
amendment by referencing the rest of the
bill um and to expand on what you were
saying um and this isn't my bill and I
didn't co-sponsor but I feel like I
understand the terminology it says on
line
14 um shall not be arrested prosecuted
or convicted for a violation of this
section line 15 if the evidence for the
charge was gained as approximate result
of the person's reporting and it's my
understanding that the way that this
terminology has historically been used
in New Hampshire law proximate meaning
like um direct result so the evidence of
prostitution would have to be acquired
after the uh sex worker what have you
has already contacted police to report
the um sexual assault so I don't know if
that addresses uh representative TRS
concerns but the way that lines 14 and
15 Read to me is that the com the
interaction between the sex worker and
police would have to begin as the sex
worker reporting the crime and then the
if during the course of that
conversation
the police conclude that there's
evidence for a charge of
prostitution they wouldn't be able to
use that evidence to support that charge
because they found the evidence during
the conversation of reporting the sexual
assault so like a real life example
would be someone's doing what they're
doing with their life and then something
goes wrong and the next day they work up
the courage to walk down to the police
department and make a report and they
sit down and have a conversation and
make maybe the police ask well what
happened that prompt that put put you in
the situation of being in a car with
this man um and then maybe she would say
well I was prostituting myself and
that's the situation that I believe this
bill and specifically lines 14 to 15 are
intended to speak to is that when that
evidence is found can you please just
although you are making an excellent
point to the underlying bill I will say
that that excellent point to the underly
Bill and that will also be relevant to
the bill whether the amendment is
adopted or not which we will
discuss I don't believe that that was
relevant to the amendment which simply
relates to whether the The Seer
reporting the sexual assault law
enforcement must cooperate so maybe we
move the question on the amendment if
and then we can discuss the underlying
merits of the bill which I think in
respect the members are having a healthy
discussion but which is it's not
necessarily is relevant to the amendment
so I seeing No Hands raised in regards
to the amendment
number 202-
us where is he yeah he's
purpose seeing No Hands raised the m
will now be put the
question if you are in support of
adopting Amendment
07 please vote yay if you are opposed
please say name first not call the
roll Vice chairman Welch hi
representative B yes representative
Spain yes representative
green
yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman
yes representative true y representative
Pratt yes representative Marston y the
clerk votes yes representative Harriet
gffr
no representative
Bixby
yes
Representative
o'n
no representative W
yes representative
Ms
yes
representative Balden
yes representative Conley yes
representative Klein Knight
yes representative Bradley
yes
chairman chair votes yes Mr chairman the
vote is 19
y by vot of
19 Y and two Nays Amendment
202- 0760 has been
adopted you wish to move now after the
pass as amended yes I move House Bill
one23 FN be ought to pass as amended do
someone wish to second that motion
second that has been seconded by
representative
Spain repres I'll recognize you to speak
if not I I would let representative
Balon pick up where I interrupted
her Let It Go B you may continue the
making thank you um well I think the
point I was building up to was about the
amendment but um the the bill let me
make sure I have that open so again it's
not my bill I'm not a co-sponsor but I
think I know what the words mean and uh
in the situation that I was talking
about if somebody's sitting in front of
a police officer making a report they've
been the victim of a crime the police
officer taking the report report and the
and it's revealed through the uh
conversation that the that the person
making the report was engaging in
prostitution um around the time that the
uh the crime happened or just the result
of the conversation um with the um
officer when the report's being made
then the officer would not be able to
use that as evidence to support a charge
against the person making the report it
seems pretty straightforward and so
consequently if um now that the
Amendments passed I suppose the effect
would be that if somebody um gets scared
uh like the uh representative earlier
was saying Whitey bulger's friend was
the was the as
salent um and they are not comfortable
continuing um it seems like they would
enjoy the the immunity regardless um
because the point is that they they had
to reveal that they were engaged in
criminal Behavior to make the report and
um it shouldn't be dependent upon uh
someone uh necessarily cooperating it's
just the fact that they had to reveal
that they were engaged in criminal
Behavior to make the report about a a
violation against
you the matter is open for discussion if
anyone representative Marson you
recognize thank you Mr
chairman I just have a question of the
last person that testified who was a
defense attorney and she was against
this bill and I got the opinion that she
thought that it could be
manipulated I asked that question tning
member here that might be able to answer
that for me I understood that concern
and I believe representative Berke and
had the similar concern and the concern
was is that basically anytime someone is
arrested or charged with prosec
try to invoke
this
defense which I believe that's a
legitimate concern but I believe in the
scenario in order this is a for this to
apply the sex worker is the person has
to contact law enforcement so in that
case if if they contact law enforcement
and report that they've been a victim of
sexual assault at that point that person
cannot be charged with with prostitution
so I don't believe that I don't agree
with with the testimony that that
scenario will become a problem because
they're reporting it represent TR had
good
hypothetical that what happens if two
officers are approaching someone that's
working as a sex work outside on on the
street and they approach the person
that's the difference there number one
is that that person did not contact is
not contacting law enforcers to report
that they were from sexual
assault thank
you representative rhod thank you Mr
chairman I think it's very important to
point out that anytime that you're
dealing with a sexual assault reporting
of a sexual
assault unless you have actual video
evidence of the
assault it's it's really going to come
down to what he said she said situation
and in order for the person to actually
be
charged you do have to
have pretty
overwhelmingly you have to have like
overwhelming testimony to be able to
prove your point so just to say as the
cop goes by oh I was assaulted by this
person you know I I have to think that
the the
officer is able to tell signs of
distress or not or the V the valid
validity thank you my friend over here
earlier you you have to be able to tell
the difference and a lot of that is
determined
by want the testimony your your your
body posture your your anger and
uh it is going to come down to he said
she said and you just have to you have
to be able to prove that with your words
so I think a lot of the testimony that
we're hearing really is just a little
bit irrelevant over being afraid that a
person might be charged you have to be
it representative Wells you recognize I
think in this bill as
amended it is two subjects here somebody
who sexually assaults
somebody and the person who gets
sexually
assaulted this bill is kind of designed
so the person who gets assaulted can get
the medical treatment the
needs and hopefully the sexual
assaulter the per gets ARR
rested me it's kind of simple and uh and
during the the period last in the last
term when we dealt with this bill I met
some of these people a couple of them
who were
assaulted and they described the
difficulty they had getting treatment
consideration when it comes
to the people who are
abusive they tend to the psychological
profiles rather consistent but they
target particular
victims they can they believe that they
can take advantage of sometimes it's not
always necessarily sex worker but sex
workers are particularly targeted and
the reason why is that there's a belief
that because they are involved in an an
act in of itself that is a criminal
offense that they're less likely to
report it making the abuse and control
easier so sex workers are are
particularly targeted by Abus of
individuals so this uh there's some hope
that this
would reduce that the frequency that at
particularly represent true thank you Mr
chair um I cannot support the
otpa um there are too
many gray areas in the
bill um and uh unended
consequences I do not see anything in
this bill that will prevent somebody who
has sexually assaulted from going to the
hospital and getting the treatment that
they
need um if uh if they were to uh to
mention to a nurse or a doctor that they
were a
prostitute I don't what the doctor I'm
going to stop treating you I'm going to
call the police and have you arrested I
don't think so I don't understand that
scenario um what one of the last uh
people
testify brought up the the the very real
possibility of false
accusations and um claiming
assault to so they cannot be charged
crime and with the
amendment they can claim
assault and not have to help the
police find the perpetrator all they
need to do is make the accusation you to
cooperate afterwards they don't have to
do any
reports therefore I don't understand
what the bill is doing I don't
understand uh what the end result would
be um and that's why I can't support
Knight thank you I'm sorry that there's
so much misunderstanding on this bill
this is simply a way for victims to get
the help that they need it's that simple
and I'm sorry for the people that
weren't here last year to hear these are
real life people they have been denied
Health Care they have been denied
services for protection and they have
been shamed and because they're working
in the shadows and that makes them open
to constantly being manipulated and
abused and if there's nobody that can
can lend them some help even in the
health care industry we've got a major
empathy problems on our hands right now
I I'm gonna challenge each and every one
of you to
please night to suggest that people lack
empathy whe because they don't support
the bill I don't believe it's
appropriate to imply that on any member
uh especially someone who hasn't we
haven't voted on yet but even if we had
imp that would be inappropriate my
apologies I meant that the intent of
this bill is to allow victims to get
health care without being prosecuted for
you representative Spain thank you Mr
chair um I'm going to say I will support
this bill
otpa I have to admit I've never been in
the situation of a sex worker seeking
medical help but I have been the parent
of a child with
disabilities and if it makes me nervous
to take my son into the emergency room
because I'm afraid that they might say
that I abused him to cause the break or
the bruise or the cut or what have you I
can only imagine the amount of distress
that somebody who was working sex might
have in the thought of even going into
an emergency want to seek help and as a
parent who's been through multiple times
having to take my son into the emergency
room and praying that they didn't think
that what he did to injure himself was
in any way some sort of abuse because I
wouldn't find out about that for days
when I finally was contacted by
authorities it's just a distressing
situation that I think that uh we can
probably put an answer
[Music]
representative thank you Mr chairman um
I guess I'm extremely confused
now I'm reading this bill and I don't
here you know I I see where you know
they can go to the hospital well you
know I don't even mention the hospital
but it just says you know they are
abused that they can reach out and tell
law enforcement and if I'm wrong I would
like somebody to explain yes I'm
wrong tell me that the dev is about
people that are abused and it's not just
women I wish people would stop saying
just women guys get abused too tell me
that this is truly for the victim not
on underlying deil it discusses some
healthare options I believe start line
15 but it's I I don't agree there
limited just to getting health
of the person making the report it's
really to report the reporting the
violent crime is
really basically getting a person that's
been sex solv into a safe environment
whether that involves them getting
healthare or not I I think it's material
that they get healthare order to invoke
this okay but it that is an option the
the problem is is that not say problem
but the concern that the amendment resol
was
that federal law will not perit the
option of getting the healthare and the
immunity side contingent on getting the
healthcare you need to separate that
requirement of cooperation that's
apparently a federal law that's based on
the Tes so the amendment clarified that
federal law conflict that I'm still I
haven't independently verified that but
that's what testimony was yes so it's
Healthcare is part of this but not it's
not the end all the all all right thank
chair has anyone uh anyone wish to speak
already
it's within the chair's discretion to
only recognize members to speak uh a
single time when it's been open to
representative bden you've already been
recognized so at this point seeing No
Hands raised from any any members who
hav't spoke
already the matter will now be put to
question if you in favor of the motion
of about to pass as amended please say y
if you oppos please say n clerk I'll
call the all than chairman Welch I
representative
ber
yes representative Spain yes
representative green
no representative Wallace yes
Representative testerman
no representative true
n representative
PR
yes representative
Marson
hey the clerk votes yes representative
Harry cther yes representative vix
yes representative
o' yes representative bour yes
representative Muse
yes representative Newman
yes representative Balden
yes representative Conley
yes representative Klein Knight
yes representative
Bradley yes
chairman chair votes
yes Mr chair the vote is 17 yay4
nay almost made to
consent by a vote of 17 Y and four
pass successful outcome that I have
gotten from the house leadership earlier
is that there actually is no hard fast
rule as to when it want consent
objective still be put
onent because it can be removed by any
member at any time there's no hard and
fast three three vote
rules you can say without objection and
then if somebody that has
voted objects then it would not go
consent let's let's try
now I'm going move for consent is there
an
objection seeing none this matter will
be put on consent sure I'll be
notified
[Music]
correct this time we will close the
executive session
on
[Music]
this time we opening the executive
session on the house bill 557 relative
to the authority of state and County
correctional facilities to discipline
image using post or solitary
confinement now recognizes
representative Wallace to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move house 557
in expedient to legisl
is there a second to that
motion that is seconded by
representative
Catt represent Wallace you wish to speak
to your motion um yes briefly thank you
sir um well the prime sponsor herself
and her testimony did say that when I
asked what the impet of this bill I
wasn't really sure I think it was an old
archaic language that turns out was
actually uh amended in 1987 so certainly
isn't that
and uh seeing that it also doesn't
eliminate the practice just the the
mention of the words there's no need for
the
Bill's doing real well with this bill
thinking it l to P testimony of various
testified basically stole a whole bunch
of
classifi got pardoned by a President
Obama uh and thinks that being a
traitor is okay but not being a
confinement I
support representative
M I'll be supporting this bill because I
think commissioner Hanks was pretty
clear that uh on the fact that uh what
this bill does and and I think the
sponsor was clear too is it bans this as
a form of of punishment but it doesn't
ban the practice in other cases when
it's
necessary um I think uh commissioner
Hanks also said she was actually looking
forward to having some of the language
uh updated because uh that that
particular section is
archaic uh so I'm I'm not sure I
understand the uh uh the opposition I'll
be voting for it I'm sorry I'll be
itl seeing no further hands
raised the matter will not be put
the close representative
Bo recognized yes thank you m chair um
well at the state prison we uh we think
that there's no real need for the bill
but that does not necessarily flow down
to uh County jails so um I'm also going
to uh oppose the itl uh in favor for
you
representative bman you
recogniz thank you um I think that maybe
there's a misunderstanding about the
testimony that was given by the
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections um there's an amendment that
the commissioner felt was important uh
to move through this committee which
would um which would give the
commissioner the
authority to discipline inmates for
specific reasons um such as attempting
to escape um or being violent so I think
that it would be wise to vote down the
itl so that we could maybe consider the
amendment that was personally drafted by
the commissioner of the Department of
Corrections so that um she could
update um the existing law to reflect
the current practice in the state
you I just may POS a question if I
understand the difference between having
the LA cified in pass as opposed to
practice but if if the practice is one
policy that is not
illegal I suppose having this pass this
bill wouldn't change how the
Commissioners are hand handling soling
saying um I'm sorry can you repeat that
there were some connection issues and I
had trouble processing your words I'll
say again if the if the this is
basically to update the the lawful
practice of how solitary confin is being
used already but I suppose
this isn't going to change any practice
being uh yes so there was a mention of
uh change as recent as I think the 80s
the um I have some research from the
research Department in the state house
showing that this was originally
codified in in the
1867 and at the time this encompassed
the entire of interactions between
correction staff and inmates um this was
uh this was really all that they needed
to say about how to run a facility and
how to discipline inmates and um back
then work was commonly um you know fied
work uh building things um work was a
lot more involved and and was far more
attached really tied to your way of um
making right with the community
uh work was an important way to um to to
pay your dues to society and that's not
so much the uh nature of incarceration
now now there's a focus on education uh
medication uh treatment things like that
and um so the the amendment that I would
like to be considered suspending for
moment you answered the question I they
give you leeway but you weren't
recognize to speak in you know just
to continue to advocate for in Opp itl
so I'm
just at this point this a simple
question that you've answered I thank
you for taking the
question representative
G just want to make sure I have this
right it it did um repal County
correctional facilities from using the
close and solitary confinement
however it didn't um the
DLC and I thought what was said was that
um they have rules in place
now that speak to um you know solitary
confinement or or using the
clothes so I say that to say that um
part of it
was you know
repealed did I get that right from what
I
yeah I defer that to the to the
committee as whole okay Amanda um
representative
Balden repres B please address the
question asked by representative
G um I'm really sorry but I is it
possible to phrase it a in a little more
concise way when time okay
Amendment
repeal the corre County correctional
facility from using um Clos or solitary
confinement yes um the answer is sort of
yes it's just that the amendment doesn't
address that portion of the existing
bill so the bill has three sections the
first section addresses the state
facility the second section addresses
County facilities and the third section
just dictates when the bill would take
effect if passed into law and the second
section addresses that the county uh
repeals the portion that allows the
county moment uh it was that was as
close to a yes to no question as water
have uh which you you did answer the
question we just and to let you go
on we can't recognize some to speak a
second time all the people which to
speak um
have the hand so if you're going beyond
appropriate representative
bsby yes uh thank you um so it the way
that I'm reading the amendment is that
the amendment replaces the entire first
section of the bill and that uh and uh
rather than just changing the language
what the amendment seems to do is set
forth a modernized um approach to how
discipline is handled by the Corrections
Department and that would be essentially
replacing what was previously uh set out
as the way that discipline was done and
that the the what the amendment does is
essentially sets in statute The
Authority for the Commissioner of
Corrections to um make rules that are uh
following modern uh best practices for
discipline so it seems like with the
amendment I could support this um uh
this bill and is the section section two
I think has been discussed is just
getting rid of what is really an archaic
thing that's not needed at the county
seeing no further hands raised oh oh
excuse
me I want to address the difference
between the state prison and the jails
and and perhaps representative Wallace
will follow along with
me in the in the jails we have two
sections of those people who are
convicted and serving their sh sentences
and we have their people awaiting trial
the people a waiting trial could be
anything from murderers to rapists you
name it and you can't make them work so
I think just repealing this section in
the County correctional business is not
a good idea correct now what the
commissioner has said about her uh State
Prison that's
good but why are we
eliminating why are we eliminating the
authority of the county Coral
jails the people who are arrested they
all all different
kind and and it's not it's a very
dangerous place in the county jail even
more so than the state
pres so I think if we're going to pass
this we should re amend it and take out
section
plane thank you Mr chair I have to agree
with the vice chair and my biggest
problem with this bill from the
beginning even looking at the amended
version has been the complete and total
repeal of section 30-b col 7 and I
actually looked it up to find out how
much was actually being repealed by that
statement and it's essentially one
paragraph that says discipline of
inmates now this was created in 1988
it's not archaic and it's not very long
ago says if any invate in the County
Correction Facility is refractory and
stubborn and refuses to work or perform
his work in a proper manner the
superintendent may put him in close
confinement until he submits to perform
his task and obey the superintendent's
orders it's as simple as that and if we
take that out
that to me means that we have removed
one method of controlling the inmates
who are unruly at the county level and
we know that the county inmates do do
work you see them out doing work jobs
often times it's voluntary and they get
asked if they want to but I'm not going
to get involved in the micromanagement
either I
yes motion is an I so I still just have
a question so section
two exists today
correct that's not something that just
right repeal on the original on the
original bill that repeals current
statute yeah yeah but that was already
there I mean that's not new no correct
that was on the original bill
know representative Newman you're
recognized thank you Mr
chair I think when we get into the
discussion of micromanagement and bills
and what should be taken out and what
should be left in it was always my
opinion that you don't necessarily have
to make all the rules and regulations
that a prison would run by by passing
legislation to ensure that that solitary
confinement is uh appropriately um
administered and I think based on the
testimony that I thought I heard was
that the commissioner also said that
they have close confinement and other
terms for what in effect fact is defecto
uh solitary confinement and those rules
are described and I think even at the
end of this bill it might say they will
be appro the best practices
appropriately described in regulations
or something to that nature because I'm
not looking at the bill because I can't
do zoom in that at the same time but
that's my opinion on whether or not and
I'm going to vote Yes for this Bill
chairman seeing your hands
raised question call the RO if you're in
favor the motion of inexpedient to
legislate please say y if you're
oppos chairman Welch hi representative B
yes representative Spain
yes representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Marston yay
clerk votes yes representative Harry G
no representative Bixby no
Representative o'n
no representative w no representative
mute
no Representative bden no Representative
connley no representative kle Knight
no representative Bradley
no chairman votes yes Mr chair the vote
is 11 yay 10
n i vot of 11 Y and 10 n the motion of
report you be preparing The Minority
Report
sure this time we now close the
executive session of the house bill
at this time we will now open the
executive session on House Bill 539
of Representative you wish recognize to
make a
second that motion has been seconded by
representative
Spain
representative speak to your
really GP
this but the more I looked into it it
actually requires the government to do
what they ought to do
is
ask
authorities into your information I'm
not even sure how to be there then but
at least this gets them out of just
making a phone call and having somebody
day
first and limiting some of their ability
to get into your
favor now the matter for discussion
representative Muse you
recognized yes thank you um uh I'm going
to oppose the motion ought to pass I I
really do wish we would have had a
little more expert testimony in this
case uh we didn't hear from uh anybody
in the carriers regarding the carriers
the Attorney General's office wasn't
available to tell us what their position
was uh on this particular issue I'm
aware of the fact that there is is a
case law uh out there that actually does
require search warrants in some states
to be uh obtained in in cases like this
um but I'm just very wary of adding
something like this to our statute uh
Without Really thoroughly vetting it uh
and I I don't really feel like we did
that today um I thought we got off to a
good start uh but to me this is a
classic example of a of a bill I think
we should be looking at a little bit
you
so one one point that I would make is in
I I do agreee with representative ton
that I had some concerns about this bill
when I first read
it what but what I was looking at here
is that it's one thing for the attorney
general or law enforcement to request
information from any communication
Comming C right from a cell phone
company they they can request
it but this the whyw is written they
they really sort of have to comply with
as long as there's some reason to
long as the AG says that we have reason
to believe that there's information on
there that will help us in an
investigation I I was under the belief
that the law would allow them the option
to comply but they don't have to the
fact that they don't really have much of
an option of not complying in my
opinion if it's not a four Comm
violation is very
close so I'm surprised if it's not if
it's a voluntary surrender just like a
voluntary search we can agree to
provide information all you want
but doesn't seem necessarily voluntary
here now
understand that's just if a cell phone
provider wanted to not cooperate really
some somebody they take pride on
customers so I'm going to support the
most of the
T
raised thank you Mr chairman I just want
to point out uh during testimony I was
very surprised by attorney Penny Dean
who at the beginning of her testimony I
thought she was going to be opposed to
this bill and in the final analysis she
was telling us she supported it and that
was strong for
me
W thank you Mr chairman I too initially
uh was somewhat opposed to the bill
thinking it had to do with metadata and
whatnot but as we peel back the Lays of
the onion it seems like this particular
Bill does do quite a bit of good to
strengthen the Privacy rights of uh ened
bill seeing No Hands raised uh the
matter will now be put to question if
you supported the motion of ought to
pass please say yay if you are opposed
please say
n than chairman Welch hi representative
Bert yes representative Spain yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yeah representative
Pratt yes representative Marston
yay the clerk votes yes representative
Harry G
nay representative Bixby
no Representative oarn
no representative
bour
Muse representative
Newman
no representative Balden
no representative Conley
yes representative Klein Knight
no representative Bradley
no chairman the chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 13 Y8
pass we bearing a majority report
Report interesting to see who the right
of minority that's
yes
at this time we now close the executive
session on House Bill
Mr yeah um just a a statement I just
heard back from superintendent Henry at
the Rockingham County Jail um and I know
we've already settled the previous bill
but in response to the uh the question
on the the county level um his words to
me in response to removing the ability
to use closer um solitary confinement
was we still need to be able to use the
solitary confinement for inmates who are
not violent who are violent or will not
behave solitary confinement could also
be used for medical issues as they need
to keep separate depends on how it's
worded so there you couldn't get back to
time
repres at this time we now to open the
exec session on House Bill
546 relative to 911 immunity for
reporting that a person has been a
546 CH I recognizes pres Ro to make a
motion to pass thank you chairman make
the motion to pass
for is there a second to that motion
second that motion has been seconded by
representative
Welch wish to speak to your motion mrman
all
the matter now be open for
discussion seeing No Hands raised the
matter will now be put to question if
you in support the motion of ought to
pass please say yay if you're opposed
please say
n Vice chairman Welch
I representative B
no representative Spain
yes representative green no
representative Wallace yes
representative
testerman
yes representative TR
y representative Pratt
no representative Marston
n the clerk votes
yes representative Harry gri yes
representative Bixby
yes representative o'n
yes representative bne
yes representative mes yes
representative
Newman
yes represent representative bden
yes representative Conley yes
representative kle Knight yes
representative Bradley yes chairman the
chair votes yes Mr chairman the vot 16
yay five Nay by vote of 16 Ys and five
passed will there be a majority
you B would you wish
prepar
sure
you prepare a Minority Report
no it be a Minority Report one of the
others I don't care if it goes on
opposed move to
consent I'm sorry make the rep our
represent Bal is who has her hand raised
report representative B must be
recognized representative Balon you you
have a
question I will phrase this as a
question do you know if a bill has a
fiscal note if it can go on
consent that's a good question fantastic
question the answer is no you're not
go
123 doesn't have but when it has the the
issue of the fiscal note is that
something
that we as a committee on and this is a
parliamentary inquiry to the vice
chair
because because the fiscal note we don't
consider the fiscal note I we obviously
that consideration that's not something
that no I think the the fiscal
note estimated increase or decrease is z
z all way corre that's correct so that's
really not that's a fiscal that means
somebody requested a fiscal analysis and
it said nothing yeah I be
recognized well you're not you're not
recogniz represent pi
yes uh on the fiscal note um the amount
of the fiscal note matters in terms of
whether it can go on consent and i' I'd
want to double check with the clerk on
this but I think that if the amount is
under 10,000 then it can go on consent I
think it's rule 35 maybe rule 37 right
all zero concr all Zer
that so I'll move I'll move with consent
if if the clerk I will consult with the
clerk has a precaution
just to make sure we're doing things the
proper
way if we I see a lot of hands raised I
will say that if we don't I don't answer
many questions we could exact more bills
so they probably have a question of the
pass thank
you thank
you
83 546 is now on consent we'll now close
546 at this
time we will open the executive session
of House
Bill uh
612 relative to the penalty for
bus representative B you were recognized
for
motion yes thank you Mr chairman I would
itl Representative Martin
second second by representative
Mar you wish to speak to your motion uh
yes Mr chairman just very briefly um you
know from the testimony I hear that our
current laws are working somewhat you
know people still you know we could pass
5,000 laws people are still going to do
it um
but
here this bill uh takes control away
from the May suspend license to shall
suspend license and I really disapprove
of that I think the uh the person in
charge of doing that should have the
authority because you know sadly
mistakes happen um I hope with those
mistakes nothing you know no children
get hurt or accidents happen but you
of you know control there and this bill
takes a lot of control away from people
you know dealing with these people that
it represent Conley you're recognized
thank you Mr
[Music]
chairman benefit of hearing this bill a
servation and
have testimony not here today aled to by
the CRI sponsor there is a real lack of
clarity for judges on how to proceive
the second offenses although we know
that there aren't that many of them
um when they you come the May versus sh
is effectively a default to not going to
suspend A license they default to not
taking that step this clarifies that for
the court essentally clarifies What's
happen um and the other thing I would
remind the committee is although there
are very few cases where second offenses
are prosecuted we heard from the
sergeant that that does not reflect
what's actually happening with the
number of times this is
occurring this bill has been you know
Vex Transportation last term uh it is
something that I struggled with around
the license suspension but um mistakes
do happen uh and um and that's where the
first offense comes in the second
offense I think is requires something
against that's seeing no further hands
raised the matter when I'll be put the
question if you in support of the motion
of inexpedient to legislate please say
yay if you are opposed to the clerk will
role just real quick I just no we have
an amendment on that we discuss that an
on Vice chairman wch
hi representative B
yes representative Spain yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Marson yay the
clerk votes yes representative harri
gather nay
representative pakus I'm sorry rep
representative VI
no Representative
o'
no representative
B
yes representative muse
no representative Newman
no representative balding no
representative Conley no represent
Knight no representative Bradley no
chairman chair votes yes Mr chairman the
vote is 12 yay n nay I a vote of 12 Y
pass represent we be preparing a
majority report I will be doing a major
majority
for
$155,000 will there be a Minority
Report that's my majority report thank
you representative
Conley this time we now close the
executive session of the house bill
612 so in regard we start out to
everyone knows with 59
bills we've now completed the public
hearing on all 59 votes we have one
outstanding executive second that we're
not going we're not going to be today we
are the calendar we are scheduled for
tomorrow we don't we're not going to
meet tomorrow there's no me for us to
meet for one executive session there
is there will be a reconsideration on on
hille
408 I believe we're gonna I'll let
everyone know the exact dat
yes no we need that needs to be just
some further research may need to be
done
there um also there was a h 205 was
retained it was a an amendment that was
repared that may be that may be
reconsidered as well so
and eventually there'll be some second
committee signment bills but we don't
need to uh we haven't got those yet so
the purposes of Tomorrow we we're going
to cancel tomorrow's hearing that
scheduled for 10
a.m. I will email the members of the
committee once I learn when that next